Isn't that cute? They're both pretending they're talking about
Ethan Klein. They're not talking about Ethan Klein, >> I
talk about Ethan Klein in this manner. >> That's it. >> Wait,
are they fighting about JTO? No, they're fighting They're fighting
about the Ethan Klein lawsuit, but Pisco is actually defending
me like but using the He's basically trying to defend me from
DGG because he's like my very good friend and he obviously wants
me to be safe. So, he's defending me from DG by criticizing Ethan
Klein. Ethan Klein is being defended the same way Destiny's defending
himself. That's how Ethan Klein is defending himself. So Destiny's
doxing campaign is being defended with the same rationale that's
being used to defend the Ethan Klein lawsuits.
Oh god. [music] Is there another Is there another Pisco argument
going on right now? Is Is Pisco arguing about this stuff again?
Oh god.
Wait, how far I I'm far enough behind. I can maybe go do some
more. >> If one of those interpretations that is psychological
danger,
if that is the mere basis of a lawsuit, that's the other problem
is going to be, you know, subjective assessments as to >> No,
I'm sorry. I do like watching it. I I just like watching it.
I'm sorry. >> Psychological danger. >> So, I could
I could give you a situation in which someone um you know, sub
Oh,
Stale 2000 in the chat. Oh, god. He actively feels
>> Is Pisco in his bedroom? I think this is his childhood
bedroom. This is like where he used to stream out of. So he get
he goes back on his old setup when he goes home. >> The
criticism is being generated on political things is psychologically
damaging them and that's all it would take or
to do with that stale 2000 or just it's too loose
>> like wait. So you're saying it's wrong.
So like someone gets harm is is is feeling psychological harm
and so they're using like a lawsuit to try to get people to [__]
off. Then you think that's wrong >> on issues unrelated
to the source of the of the harm,
right?
I feel so for example, right? The take the bold guy video itself.
>> You're not No, no, you're you're getting disconnected
from the argument I was making. The argument I was making is
that he felt like
>> tail is not her husband. It's fake news. It's just funny.
the actions that they took post nuke like the call and those
other things were a continuation in the pattern of actions that
came before it.
>> All right. You just a lot of people feel that way. >> Yeah.
You just I said at the very beginning so so you just backed up
again the whole like >> at the very beginning of the segment
I said these are these are continuation of a pattern of behavior
in the minds of the people that disagree with you and I would
say likely in the mind of age three. I I'm trying to respect
your you, right? I'm trying to respect your
>> And if I can't >> I'm trying to respect your you
>> understand what is causing you to have a disposition
one way or the other.
It is It's impossible for me to >> Wait, hold on. Alien
mode doesn't know why that's it. I'm committing Harakiri.
You don't think it can tell that you're saying you're going to
do it? You're going to end it all? You're asking what was automotted.
You're saying you're going to kill yourself. That's what's getting
automoded. How are you confused on that? It would be respectful
to your view. And so when you back up and talk about course of
conduct before we've understood the full implications or even
meaning of this feeling like he's that they're in danger, then
you understand that it makes the conversation feel I
>> this concept is clearly important to you and I can't
address it because a I don't understand it and b you don't have
like a full elaboration of it. So backing up and talking about
the course of conduct is just a way to
um filibuster. Unfortunately, I'm not saying that's your intent.
I'm just like I am trying to be respectful. >> Well, but
like what what are what are you trying to cut to
that this is getting in the way of? >> What I'm trying
to cut to is that the mere subjective beliefs of a person can
with respect to the danger they're facing on on collateral issues.
Uh, and if that danger includes things like psychological damage,
that if that were a proper purpose to bring the, you know, lawsuits
that are totally unconnected to the source of that harm, then
that would justify pretty much anything.
It's too loose. >> The reason you can't let Trump get away
with the rationale
or
MAGA people that like he really thought he won the election,
guys, so like he has to be able to do this, right?
It's just basically your subjective belief isn't enough reason
to do crazy. >> it it's basically rebranding and
um moral faults from other actors. And instead of thinking about
the intentions and dispositions of the people who are at fault
for those moral wrongs, it's all about the subjective head of
the purported victim. And no matter how well-meaning, now I'm
not saying they're well-meaning, but no matter how well-meaning
the critics are, they are going to be subject to certain tactics,
even if they're doing nothing that's morally harmful. I'm not
saying they're not. And Dude, Pisco just keeps arguing.
Isn't it when Pisc is like, "Yeah, it's totally insane to excuse
Destiny's doxing campaign just because he feels like he's under
attack and he's not thinking at all about the actual moral wrongs
done to him and who has done them. Everybody's like excusing
his behavior cuz they're like, "Oh, well, he his friends were
getting harassed or something." But nobody actually thinks about
who was doing it or why they were doing it. And so other actors
who are critics of him are just getting lumped in and and that's
crazy. When Pesco said exactly those words, I a tear rolled down
my face. Okay. It's so cool that he can actually criticize Destiny
with the thin veil of the Ethan lawsuit. I really appreciate
that. Okay. >> In the real world, but your standard of
subjective beliefs of danger is untenable.
It there needs to be some way to incorporate the culpable conduct
of
Everything about Ethan's intent is vibes, right? No. He's also
made statements and where those statements are clearly contradictory
with like previously stated facts, previously stated opinions,
you can make some
obviously, but you've been watching even >> from the subjective
view of the victim.
>> All right. Okay.
>> Peace. I love you and I'm sorry if this is about to
end this conversation because genuinely what you just said to
me sounds like such a filibuster. You are telling me that people
coming to the legal system with subjective
beliefs
shouldn't bring lawsuits
when the whole point of the >> dude
uh
second the whole point of the law
>> he is legally allowed to file a lawsuit because I also
in the way I criticize Pisco would also admit all you have to
do to get your little bit of sanity back is the people who make
this same disagreement okay is just say, "Wait, Piscar, are you
saying that he can't file the lawsuit because of your subjective
opinion?" No, nobody's saying that. He can obviously file the
lawsuit, but I will criticize him. It is my subjective experience
that Ethan Klein is a douchebag. Is my subjective opinion that
Ethan Klein is a douchebag who's filing this maliciously. Right?
Here's the evidence I have for it. It's not just a feeling I
have. Here's the evidence I have for it. And if you want to fight
on the evidence and say, "I shouldn't think that for another
reason," I'm happy to do that. But you don't want to do that.
You just want to go, are you saying he shouldn't file that lawsuit?
Yes, but I'm saying he can, but he shouldn't because it's bad.
>> Is that you have a subjective view of a situation and
you need a third party to factfinder to sort it out and tell
you if it's good or not? >> No, he can file the lawsuit,
but then when I criticize him and say, "This is what I think
about your lawsuit." and he basically makes some [__]
up about me instead of actually engaging with the criticism,
then I have a good idea that he is lying when he states his belief
or his intent.
>> That is now you can tell me, well, there's a subjective
view that's not related to the lawsuit and so then that's the
problem that they're bringing. Okay, fair enough. Wait, subjective
ideas are the basis of >> No, do you think we're talking
about what do you think I'm telling you that he can't legally
file that lawsuit? What do you think I'm saying?
Wait, are they fighting about JTO? No, they're fighting They're
fighting about the Ethan Klein lawsuit, but Pisco is actually
defending me
like but using the He's basically trying to defend me from DG
because he's like my very good friend and he obviously wants
me to be safe. So, he's defending me from DG by criticizing Ethan
Klein. Ethan Klein is being defended the same way Destiny's defending
himself. That's how Ethan Klein is defending himself. So Destiny's
doxing campaign is being defended with the same rationale that's
being used to defend the Ethan Klein lawsuits,
right?
And so Pisco is very cleverly couching his defense of me in only
criticizing Ethan Klein and not Destiny directly, but by by making
it very obvious for everybody that the logic is almost one to
one >> descriptively the basis of lawsuits. >> What
is it that you think that we're talking about
>> right now?
We're talking about why H3 could have brought this lawsuit and
whether it's good or not and whether that's an ethical thing
for him to do or not. And I'm saying I think he brought this
lawsuit because he felt some level of of danger towards his ability
to make money as an online streamer. I think that's true. And
I think that that is sufficient for him to bring >> That's
that's Oh, it's funny. He's talking to Cfka Esquire, the guy
who defends Destiny. And they're both pretending they're talking
about Ethan
Isn't that cute? They're both pretending they're talking about
Ethan Klein. They're not talking about Ethan Klein, >> I
copy in this manner. That's it. That's a to me. >> So,
so you don't want to actually have the conversation. You just
totally mischaracterized my view about what >> I No, no.
I just told you my view.
>> That's what I did. So >> if you have a problem
with that view, you can internally critique it. >> I do
have a problem with that view. Okay.
So
does the feeling that you the subjective feeling that you're
um Why did you laugh >> No, I'm just Oh, no, no, no. Whenever
I said okay and I laughed, sorry, I'm a little amped. So we're
we're we're conflicting with each other. So, >> does the
subjective
>> does the subjective feeling
of
incoming financial damage
from true
and vicious critique that is accurate, right? We're just This
is a
>> And the design Yes. Yeah. Oh, Pisco's got it. Wait,
you understand that? like real honest critique that was insightful
and clearly true would be extremely harmful to somebody's bottom
line. Do you still believe that that is not something that that
is something you should be sued over? Obvious moral answer would
be no. You're saying true things about somebody. Should you be
sued? Should you be harmed in return? Is that okay for somebody
who is who is a harmful actor faces a critique based on that
harm and they sue or try to harm somebody in return despite the
critiques being true? Obviously that is bad. Obviously that is
something we all dislike as like a society as human beings. It's
not even like you don't even have to go
Yeah. You don't have to go anywhere. It's just obviously true.
We all hate that. That idea is up to everybody. desire to silence
that true vicious critique and silence future criticism. Does
that justify
on the basis of potential future monetary harm
this lawsuit?
CFKA
does this justify and the potential of future harm
a totally deranged doxing campaign was what Pisco said there
if you could translate into like what the real if you can read
between the lines. Okay, if you can if you can observe this from
the the plane of the schizosphere. Okay, you're looking down
on the on the projection, okay, the stereographic projection
of the schizosphere onto reality and you can translate this.
It is Do you think this really justifies Desessie's doxing campaign
that there's like vicious critique being done of him?
by the way, that's not what Pisco is doing. I should just actually
make it clear that's not what Pisco is doing. The arguments happen
to line up. I'm just being like clever about it. It is funny.
The arguments are one to one though. They are like actually one
to one. Yeah. Yeah. That's me. That's me playing the goofy background
music alien >> Right. So, >> it's basically so that
if I go silent, you can hear that the stream isn't buffering.
So, if you're only listening, you can hear that the stream isn't
buffering. There's like a little sound going on still. It's just
a signal that the stream is still happening. >> Example
I'm giving you because you said subjective belief as to harm
regarding
um monetary compensation with their
Does the pure motive to silence critics that would have an effect
on bottom lines, would that justify this copyright
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. >> Does
the
pure motive to silence critics that would have an effect on bottom
lines,
would that justify this copyright
>> No. For just silencing critics, no. But but what if
the theory what if someone says to you the reason I'm silencing
the critics is because if I don't they will hurt my business.
>> Because in that scenario what I would say is those are
actors
acting within a market
affecting you via tools of the market harm your performance in
the market. And that's might be just me being lawyerrained on
>> Okay. So, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. How is that not
how is that not what Denims was doing? >> You acting with
an >> How do you How do you morally disag like disagree
that that's what Denims was doing? That is what Denims was doing.
Like, clearly he was doing the same thing everybody else did,
right? I Oh, toxopplasmosis, you just said something completely
moronic. I got to time you for an hour. Back in an hour or something.
There's literally that you literally can't hear the music at
any point. you're just you're actually brain >> in a market.
You don't get to use a lawsuit to stop them from doing that.
I think that for him the monetary harms were not that these people
were out competing him. I don't think that these people were
somehow coming up with ways in which to better market to his
audience to steal it. I think they were acting in ways that were
counter or outside of market purposes. And a lawsuit is the correct
avenue to correct those things. That is literally back up.
>> So if Ethan had said
>> Pisco, this guy knows Pisco just got him in the hypothetical
and so he's sprinting away, right? He's sprinting away. He had
to go back to the current situation and say how it doesn't apply.
Pisco is walking you down some hypotheticals because he can see
he can see that the where your opinion is going to fail. It's
not right here. Yes, this is not one to one. This is not precisely
analogous,
but this guy's running away because he sees the vision >> that
like these people are harming me with their criticism and their
lies about me. They're like hurting the business. They're telling
people that I'm in favor of genocide. They're they're lying about
Ela, but all stuff that's protected. Okay, there these people
who are lying, these people who are um spreading narratives about
his political beliefs, these people who are snarking him with
respect to criticism. If all of that were true and Ethan says
this is being the reason I'm doing this is specifically to get
them to stop
the criticism because it's hurting me psychologically and it's
hurting my bottom line. And the way I'm going to do that is punishing
uh individuals who are part of that criticism, part of what's
saying if if if
>> all of it's true
and everything they're saying is true.
All right. And it's only the criticism and he's saying I hate
that. So I'm going to assume to try to get him to stop. That's
what you're saying the scenario is.
Um, one second. I'm just thinking about it real quick because
I I want to I want to give you the answer that I genuinely feel.
So, let me slow down and think.
>> I think in that scenario in that scenario, I think it
would it it would be an it would be an unethical thing, especially
based off of that motive.
him say right like we know the motive there and we're saying
he's trying to silence good faith detractors who are bringing
true criticism >> no my example it's lies my example some
of it's lies lies >> yeah some of it's lies some it's fine
>> no but it's protected it's part of the
>> I don't care about whether or not it's protected speech
or not he's not suing them for their speech that's what the protection
did if it wasn't protected just sue them for the speech right
So he's finding >> protected so they're lucky they don't
get sued for that but then they do some kind of behavior that
makes them vulnerable to liability. He can sue him. That's not
but fine. Okay. >> We're not guess what wait we're not
asking can he sue. >> No I didn't say I said it was fine.
I said it's ethical that he sued. I didn't say can. I said he
it's good.
>> You said can it's fine. Those people throughout the
entirety of that lawsuit and after that lawsuit will get to keep
saying those lies about him. So their ability to use that protective
speech hasn't gone away.
That would be that would be true of the the case in which they
were saying true criticism trying to stifle those and that in
that
>> how is it
>> how is he stifling the lies? How is he stifling the
lies by this lip lawsuit? >> So Pisco is trying to say
that some of the statements they're making aren't like malicious
lies or lies outright. They're like interpretations of things
that are reasonable that Ethan knows aren't true, but Ethan has
not necessarily shown himself to be trustworthy actor. So, there's
some level of criticism mixed with like untruths that can't be
proven from Ethan's side and he feels like they're lies. It's
like the difference between a knowing like intentional lie and
just like saying things that reasonable people could think based
on the stuff you're seeing, right? It's that subjective difference.
And Pesco probably thinks that it's bad to sue based on that
subjective difference, right? in a different way. That's not
like basically if you wanted to litigate whether or not it was
lies, you wanted to get apologies on that, you would go and file
a cease and desist and then you would file a defamation claim,
right? But he doesn't want to do that. He just wants to hurt
them based on things he thinks are lies, but doesn't know they're
lies and really are probably reasonable when you stop and think
about it. And so what he's not what he's trying to do would apply
to actual like effective good criticisms where Ethan just didn't
see himself subjectively the same way. he would still feel like
that's harmful, like those are wrong, right? And then he could
sue people who are making good subjective criticisms of him.
And so he is actually silencing critics. He's he's you're giving
him the green light to silence critics without drawing a firm
line here. I think that's probably where Pisco is going, right?
>> You're now asking about the actual case. >> Why
are you doing that? >> Why are you Why do you keep doing
this? If people are criticizing him with lies, is it okay to
bring a lawsuit against them for IP infringement?
>> Is that not the hypothetical? >> I'm trying to
distinguish your view of when it's acceptable as a motivation
to
have silencing criticism
um to justify the lawsuit.
He's trying to generate a rule independent of Ethan Klein, independent
of a specific situation.
CFKA defends the doxing campaign. So CFKA knows Kfka is actually
defending two situations at the same time. Ethan Klein and the
doxing campaign, right? And so Pisco is basically going to try
to make him generate a rule that makes both of those okay and
doesn't make him sound like a total totally immoral psychopath.
I don't believe you can thread this needle. That's why CFKA is
struggling. That's why CFKA keeps trying to collapse it back
to just one of these things. Pisco isn't trying, I don't think,
intentionally to make CFKA like stop defending Destiny or something.
What I think Pisco is trying to do, cuz he does this all the
time, is just figure out your generalized rule set for how you
look at this situation outside of Ethan Klein specifically. What
is your rule? What is your principle that leads you to believe
what you're saying right now? So, that's what he's trying to
do. He's trying to get this well he's trying to get this
to go like he's trying to say I need your generalized rule. And
I think this is why Kfka is like having a struggle right now
is he's trying to defend two things at the same time and he can't.
So he's collapsing it back to Ethan Klein and then Pisco is going
no no just generate a rule. I think that's where Kfka is really
>> on the sort of idea that it would harm your bottom line
and psychological damage. And you seem to grant there's two cases,
right? That it would be improper in the case of like true statements
are accurate and good faith, but it >> would be justified
if it's like bad faith criticism. And I'm seeing like what what
is the difference? Why are those different >> because in
one case people are acting in an unethical way against you
>> and I prescribe to the theory of tit fortat and this
would be a tat. They are acting unethical at me. >> Do
you see? Do you see? I see all things at all times. Nothing is
beyond my vision. I can call this out instantly. Recon Quest,
thank you for the very much. Oh, thank you very much for the
100 kicks and thank you for the sub earlier. I didn't thank you
for that. Thank you so much. >> That doesn't that >> Yeah,
but you see exact it's exactly what I said, right? And he has
to go to the Destiny explanation for it. Oh, it's actually to
for [laughter] >> I'm going to act in a way that harms
you to get you to stop acting unethically towards me. >> So
why wouldn't that justify doing the frivolous lawsuit? >> Because
I think a frivolous lawsuit goes beyond and is now acting in
a way that is beyond the the the bounds of these two these actors.
I'm now involving a greater harm than merely just the right.
>> It's not enough. That's what I mean. It's not enough
to say that one side is doing a harm to another. You still have
to you still have to make some sort of uh argument about the
response. >> I believe yeah proportion yeah proportionality
does come into my
>> What uhhuh and this is this is where all the lies come
in. This is where I go hey prove anything you're saying and they
go oh it's obvious. It's obvious. It's >> So just saying
well they're doing something bad against him doesn't resolve
the issue because that would be true of a frivolous lawsuit.
It would be true of hiring a hitman. It would be true of doing
reverse CPS. It would be true of spreading lies. Like you wouldn't
justify, do you think it would be justified? I'll ask you this.
To spread lies about denims. >> Would Would H3 be justified
in spreading lies against denims? >> Yeah, that's that's
as tip for tat as you can get. Right. >> Well, it is tit
for tat. I actually
I would say >> you wait. You totally endorse tit for tat.
Like totally
Totally immoral behavior is fine so long as you could say you
reasonably suspect the other person is engaging in immoral behavior
against you, right? Isn't that >> To lying.
No, I also put lying pretty high up on pretty unethical. >> This
is what this is like what I don't understand, right? Because
everyone kind of agrees that or I think people agree that it
wouldn't be justified in response to lies, criticisms. Again,
you know, a lot of that's subjective in terms of the criticism
with respect to the political stuff, but even assuming that's
a lie, nobody seems to be willing to bite the bullet that it
would be justified to lie in response. Some people might. >> Yeah.
But but
Right. Okay. Sure. >> I truly don't understand how KFKA
says, "Oh, you can't engage in unethical behavior in response."
I I have no idea how he just said that to Pisco with a straight
face. >> Right. So, if it wouldn't be even justified to
lie in response,
why would it be justified to lie about a lawsuit and then actually
file that lawsuit
against that person? What in what respect is that more proportional
than just a direct lie? >> Wait, what do you mean? So,
what
now? Wait, this is a fact question. This is a fact question.
>> Where the lie about the lawsuit. Tell me what you view
as a lie about the >> Wait on this. >> Okay. We we
will definitely go. >> What are you Is this a hypothetical
>> So this would be the lie would be that you are going
to engage in this behavior. You're going to file this lawsuit.
You're filing this lawsuit because you are hurt by these people.
You are hurt emotionally. You are hurt. You could argue financially,
although I don't believe it's financial for him at all. I think
it's emotionally. He's hurt emotionally. And if he files those
lawsuits and tells the truth and says, "I'm hurt emotionally,
then he he's never going to be like forgiven for that, right?"
So, he makes up a he makes up some pretext for filing the lawsuit.
Um, yeah. And and that seems unethical. Also, I do believe he's
straight up lied about the conduct Denims is engaged in. Like,
I think there's multiple lies about what conduct Denims is engaged
in and how he separates it from other people's conduct.
Maybe uh at this basis you could still maybe justify the Casey
thing. The lawsuit itself probably not the settlement but the
lawsuit itself for Denims I think you're still at the line >> applying
it to I think I think you actually lied but but getting into
the facts now the reason why getting into the facts now will
confuse the issue is we won't know your test. That's why we're
using these hypotheticals is to not establish some kind of like
ad hoc test but some kind of principled test. You want a principal
test, don't you? You want a consistent framework, don't >> For
the most part, yes. >> And what? So, so I'll just say like,
is anybody not following? If I wasn't telling you what Pisco
is saying, would you have a hard time understanding what Pisco
is saying? Genuine question cuz like that seems to be the problem
everyone is running into is like I think they they don't seem
to understand what he's saying. But I find it so easy. It's like
clear. It's crystal crystal crystal clear to me what Pisco is
saying.
And I don't think I'm required to fill in these gaps. But then
I listen to how other people interpret what he's saying.
And and they like can't interpret what he they they're like,
"Oh, I have no idea what he's saying." They're like
And so I I just find it very strange when I see other people
trying to interpret what he's saying and they fail completely.
And then I'm looking at it, I'm like, dude, it's obvious to me.
Well, Kilo, and do you does anybody disagree with me that I think
the reason Kfka doesn't want to generate a rule is because he
he can't generate a rule that doesn't get him in trouble with
the main community he's a part of and also doesn't make him look
like a complete the Pisco and Pisco's community,
right? Like there is there's no rule that exists that lets you
defend both Ethan and Destiny and not look like a totally immoral
psychopath. Yeah. Yeah. Listen to what I just said cuz I think
I said that as you were typing that argument out. I do believe
this is the problem for CFKA and a lot of other people is that
Pisco
he tries to pull this back to a I said this like earlier. I think
this is maybe something people don't get but Pisco said it explicitly
now. When he was asking questions, I tried to explain that he's
trying to extract a generalizable rule that you could apply to
other situations.
That is something people will resist because you can't create
a a respectable
like genuine generalized rule set that defends Ethan Klein and
the Destiny doxing campaign,
right? You can't do these things. It just doesn't work. >> What
respect don't. And so that's that's why they're all resistant
to going down this generalized route and they'll go, "Well, that
that doesn't necessarily make sense in the Ethan Klein case because
it's like, "No, no, no. I'm trying to help you right now. Don't
worry about it." They're like, "No, I don't like this. I don't
like answering >> Don't you want a consistent frame?
>> You might want one that is a framework that is um loose
enough that allows a case by case basis where you're merely
>> right? But applying That's telling. That's telling.
Well, you might want That's very telling.
Why wouldn't you want a consistent framework, CFKA? Why wouldn't
you want >> You might want one that is a framework that
is um loose enough that allows a case by case basis where you're
merely
>> right? But applying number of factors. >> Yeah.
Yeah. But applying a consistent set of factors that are apt in
the case and that are consistent across like cases, right? You
don't want some ads
>> Sure. But I'm I'm speaking more of like kind of >> Dude,
it's like so
I'm not that smart that I'm like that I'm like divining things
that are impossible to see. I'm like not that smart. I know that
I'm humble enough that I can go I'm seeing something that's like
pretty transparent on its surface and I'm describing it but it's
like very obvious what's happening and then I I say it. I predict
what's going to happen and then it it like actually plays out
one to one. I'm just like I'm elated. I love when like the world
operates in the exact way I expect is it's like a touchstone
on reality. Reality is what I think it is, right? I don't know.
I can't describe it. I feel like nobody gets that feeling anymore.
They don't like being like they don't like having their thoughts,
their predictions like play out in reality. They just don't care.
They're just like, I'm going to I'm going to say what I think.
I'm going to say this totally insane thing that'll never happen.
>> So, I don't know.
>> A a concept of equity that goes beyond merely
a a rigid structure. I'm I'm a big equity guy. I believe that
there are while while rigid structures are good in a lot of ways
I think there is uh there are times in which they are not >> So
so getting into the facts right now and me talking about what
I think he lied about is going to confuse our actual test whatever
our framework that we want to apply is because right now the
reason I'm throwing all these hypotheticals is to try to build
out a structure before we apply
the facts. I want to know what like this is why I get so frustrated
with people who are um who are like trying to say this is all
stupid is it would be like going to I'm going to declare right
now that like everybody pretending this doesn't make sense or
they can't see it is probably
with a very like just mo motivated to be performatively in this
one case. It's like very obvious what's happening. It's it's
just
cuz it's not it's not that >> Legal analysis
without knowing what the test is and trying to apply it. We need
to know what the test is. We need to know what our rule is, you
know? >> You sure? Yeah. Fair. >> So that's why I'm
saying like
that's why I'm trying to keep us to the dialectic that we're
doing so far. What we have so far is uh the hypothetical in which
there are a bunch of people who are saying bad faith criticisms
and lies about a creator and you just said right you wouldn't
support as ethically correct
lies in response from the creator to that that would be you wouldn't
support that you would say that was wrong to do you know just
because denims lies about you don't think that it's justified
to lie about her and that is I think If that's the >> substance,
stop taking spoilers from me into the future because we're only
we're like 20 minutes behind. You're like an hour in the future.
Taking spoilers from me, sending them into the future. What are
you doing, man? I'm going to give you a kind of greater includes
the lesser argument, which is if it's not even justified to lie
in response to
how would it be justified to lie about a lawsuit, assuming you
did, and then file that lawsuit again for all the for things
that >> I think what Pisco is trying to do here is allow
for basically there's like something there's something where
somebody says something about you that is a reasonable thing
to think that you know isn't true, right? And you say it's a
lie, but you can't show why it's not true. Like they're not a
bad actor. There might be something there, but your like subjective
experience or maybe it's just an opinion. You think it's wrong
and you call it a lie. It's like your subjective experience probably
shouldn't be what dictates that. Other people around you dictate
that. doesn't prevent you from filing the lawsuit, but like there
there should be some test of you you being able to be honest
about what your motivation is so that you don't and the lie about
the motivation is what tells you that he knows he's doing something
wrong because if he actually thought he was acting correctly,
he wouldn't lie about his motivation for doing it. Right? And
this is the again one to one with the Destiny case where Destiny
has to lie about his motivation for doing it. He has to say these
people helped dox people around me. They helped they helped go
after people around me. He has to say that, right? He has to
lie about his motivation because if he just said, "I don't like
that they're being mean to me." He would look like a [__]
He would look like the biggest [__] on planet Earth
that are collateral to it.
It seems like the greater includes lesser. One of them is just
lie, which you say is unjustified. The other one includes a lie,
but then it also includes a lawsuit on the collateral issue for
which the person doesn't care about the underlying infringement.
It just seems like the greater includes the lesser there. You
understand? >> I'm not sure I follow you. I I understand
what your argument is. I'm just trying to not follow you to that
conclusion. I think that lying for your motiv lying regarding
your motivations for bringing a lawsuit, I I I don't know how
much ethical weight to put on that compared to lying about a
person.
>> Why do you lie about your motivations for carrying out
a lawsuit? Right? Why do you why do you lie about that? Why would
you lie about that? Just think of the most likely reason. Hey,
you just punched that guy in the face. Why'd you do that?
Well, actually, he pulled a knife on me and threatened to kill
me. So I I punched him in the face. Sounds a lot better than
well, he like said I look fat and so I punched him in the face.
So that's basically what the suggestion is that's going on here,
right? Is Ethan Klein has a small petty motivation for doing
this and he lies and says it's a grander, more noble thing because
he doesn't want the actual criticism that should go along with
his actions
>> Yeah. You think you think you will be judged based on
your motivations and so you lie about them. you know that you'll
be judged. And by the way, if you if you have a good idea that
you're going to be judged based on your motivations, that probably
should make you pause and go, "Wait, are my motivations like
actually good?" Wow. Well, I don't I mean, really? I mean, like,
so lying about something trivial about that person as opposed
to lying about the major thing you're bringing to lawsuit? you
I don't think that you can >> I don't know I I don't know
what value the like I don't I don't know
what harm is being done by a person lying about why they bring
a lawsuit to the public when the public has no entitlement
to the knowledge
>> okay
here oh dude the desk having two cases is very instructive when
it's basically the same thing the reason you do that is because
what you're actually looking what you're actually seeking with
the lawsuit is to shape public opinion. And I don't think that
CFKA is even really fighting that, that it's to silence criticism.
CFKA, they probably just argue on how valid the criticism is,
right? How much it strains into uh strains away from fact. And
so when you're seeking to to change public opinion on something,
i.e. you're trying to get people on your side so that you could
do something bad to your critics,
of course you're going to lie. And of course, that lie is bad
and you can make moral judgments on it. You want to do a bad
thing and be lauded for it and so you lie about why you're doing
it.
That is obviously a a moral wrong in and of itself, right? And
you can judge you can judge those moral intentions. Sorry, you
can judge those intentions on a moral
>> Obviously
of why they brought the lawsuit. I don't like that's kind of
a lie where it's like what's the
>> harm? What's the harm in lying to the general public
about >> about why I'm bringing a lawsuit against another
personal party? I think it's totally appropriate for people to
lie about why they bring lawsuits all the time. Of course, >> you
think it's someone walks up and >> you think it's appropriate
to lie about why you're bringing a lawsuit?
>> Do you think it's appropriate to lie to the police?
If it Yeah. >> In general, no.
>> We're talking about morals. Do you think it's appropriate
to lie to the police? No. I mean, probably if you kill somebody,
the moral thing to do is to confess. Actually, do you think it's
do you think it's immoral to lie to the police? Yeah, probably.
In like a lot of cases, there might be some edge cases where
you don't talk to the cops, lying to the cops or not talking
to the cops is all about protecting yourself,
but it's not about moral action. It's about protecting you, making
sure you don't get hurt.
Protecting yourself is not moral unless you're a narcissist.
>> If you're Oh, that's >> You think it's appropriate
to lie? I could be harmed. If I could be harmed personally by
telling the the police the truth. All right.
Come on. If this if he's,
>> dude, look at this. Look at the Look at the nuts this
guy has to tie himself in.
If I If I told the truth to a place and it hurt me, well, why
would I do that? Um, we're talking about morals. If you kill
somebody, you morally should turn yourself into the police. Are
you serious right now? >> You can just say nothing. >> Why
is the lawsuit taking it hard? You could Hey, guess what? H3,
it would have been a better move to say nothing >> in virtue
of what would be better lying about his law. >> He just
gave away the whole this guy's is this guy really a lawyer? This
guy's a complete
Why would it be better for him to say nothing? Because it was
bad to lie. You idiot. He just gave it. He doesn't even realize
it. He's just having a conversation. He's just shooting from
the hip. He doesn't realize he just gave the whole game away.
Pisco doesn't miss >> It would have been a better move
to say >> In virtue of what would it be better lying about
his lawsuit? >> In virtue of what would it be better? >> Better
than
>> because you shouldn't talk publicly about lawsuits that
you that you're undergoing.
Especially ones. [laughter]
>> He's just trying to change it. Oh, it would be better
cuz you shouldn't ever talk about he just invoked a different
principle. That's not what he was talking about. That's that
he's right now CFKA is lying to the cops, okay? Because he just
said something and Pisco caught it and he immediately backs up
and goes, "Well, actually, I have this other principle. You should
just never talk about your lawsuits publicly." Morally, it's
a moral wrong to talk about your lawsuits publicly. Oh, really?
CFKA
CFKA Esquires now on the page of it's a moral wrong to talk about
your lawsuits publicly.
Incredible.
Uh he might not say it's a moral wrong here, but that's >> because
you shouldn't talk publicly about lawsuits that you that you're
>> Oh, never mind. He says you should not.
>> Yeah. Should not. You ought not.
So, never mind. He did make them work. >> Especially ones
in which people have a vested interest to try to undermine and
harm in ways that are against your interest. So, telling the
truth or lying publicly would have been a was a worse move than
um saying nothing.
This is >> I don't >> Well, hold on. Pisco needs
to delineate. Okay, here between is it a worse move for your
own personal interest? Because if you want me to tell you that
Ethan lying about his rationale is good for him. I'm going to
give you that every day of the week. We're talking about morality
here. Is it a good act? Is it a good act,
Um, actually, the best thing for him is to lie. Yeah. No,
that's why I think he's lying. [laughter] don't understand how
so like by this why would it be wrong for Hassan to lie about
caller gate? >> Um why would it be wrong? I mean I think
that one is more >> I'll just I'll just ask you. WAS IT
>> WAIT, HOLD ON. I WAS WALKING TO THE BATHROOM. I had
to come back. THAT IS A POWER bomb right there.
Wait, why is it wrong why is it wrong for son to lie about Colgate?
Why would that be wrong? Where's the moral wrong there? He's
down the the lane of trying to argue that lying is not bad. That's
crazy. >> Why would it be wrong? I mean, I think that one
is more I'll just ask you. Was it wrong for Hassan to lie about
>> Um, yeah. No. Yeah, that's pretty clearly wrong for
him to do that. >> Okay. Was it wrong for Hassan to lie
about how long he was detained in uh by
>> Was it wrong for Ethan to lie about if he did lie about
the motivation of his lawsuit? I mean like yes, but I would say
to I'll say yes. I won't give you qualifiers. I'll say yes. And
if we want to get into the differences, we can, but I'll just
say yes. Okay. So, it is a self-standing wrong. There's no like
unless there's some overriding good reason to lie. I will admit
that there are some lies that are justified.
I'm not saying every lie is unjustified, but unless there's a
good reason to lie, we're going to say in general lying is wrong.
Right. >> It's about like what is your Yeah. It's about
what your rationale for lying is. Who are you helping? Are you
making the world a better place by lying?
Well, maybe you have an argument then. If you're if you're just
prioritizing yourself over everybody else, that can't be a moral
good. You can't say it's morally correct to prioritize myself
above everyone else all the time. That's insane,
right?
>> So, it's it's not enough to say, "Well, you're lying
about the lawsuit or lying to the police." that doesn't make
it uh that's not by itself a good enough reason to lie just because
it relates to lawsuits or it's to the police, >> right?
But in both scenarios, I would sit there and wait to hear the
justification before saying whether or
>> So assume assuming Ethan did lie about his motivations.
What would be the justification for it? >> There's a very
large amount of people online that he feels like are endangering
his ability to make money, his physical health, his mental health,
his family, his reputation.
>> that justifies lying about and that justifies lying
if he did lie. >> That could it very well could. He might
have reasons to think that doing so was to his benefit. Uh and
it would justify >> Wait, what if Ethan was like a bad
actor? Like what if you were actually making these same arguments
on like in favor of Nick Fuentes? Like what would you make these
same arguments in favor of Nick Fuentes that it's like good for
him to lie about certain things to prioritize his well-being,
his family's health, his like business,
right? For him to lie about things he said in the past or lies
in ways that like help him destroy his enemies. Would it be good
then? I feel like this is just wrong. Like lying about lying
about to hurt other people to preserve yourself because they
have valid criticisms of you or they have criticisms that you
basically can't disprove that you are like are nebulous in some
way. You can't just defend that,
right? Or lying about your reasoning for >> by him lying
about it. Yeah. >> If Assan sued
um Loner Box and or copyright infringement and lied about why
he was doing it, >> would you say the same thing?
And Hassan thought that Loner Box was uh gener
>> better test. Hassan's a better test cuz these people
hate Hassan way more than they hate Nick Fentes. >> Like
hate brigades at him and generating
And in in the realm of speculation about whether it was ethical
or not, yes, I would say I'm going to withhold judgment on whether
or not it's ethical or not until without without pretty concrete
proof that there was no justification in doing that. >> No,
we would say it's wrong. Of course, it's wrong for to do that.
>> You would say to lie about it. So, so Lonerbox almost
certainly has infringed on e on Hassan's copyright.
>> Agreed. Right. >> He hasn't or he has. He almost
certainly has infringed on Hassan's copyright from a legal perspective.
>> This would be by virtue of watching, you know, long
segments of content without like without having pre-filtered
it
doing like a on the-fly reaction. >> I This is just I don't
engage a lot with Loner Box's stuff. I Yes, sure. I don't know.
He He seems like a great person. I just don't engage a lot. >> I
like Loner Box. I I I like Loner Box. I like Hutch. I'm a lib.
All right. I'm >> This is what I'm talking about. Yeah.
Basically, when I watch him play World of Warcraft to play a
video game and throw a video up, I don't see a ton of >> Not
that it's like totally not there, but I don't see >> [__]
lib. Apparently, I'm the last samurai lib principal lib somewhere.
Anyway, um the So, Loner Box is almost certainly infringed on
Hassan's uh content. If Hassan sued Loner Box and then said,
"I'm doing this to protect and to bring in like the the proletariat
revolution or something." And so he's clearly lying because he
any loser knows that a single copyright infringement isn't going
to bring about the uh socialism, right? If he did that, we would
all say, "What a what a lie. That's wrong." And we wouldn't have
any we wouldn't have any
kind of like that. Well, because it might benefit him to lie,
therefore he should, >> right? I think well I agree but
I I'm agreeing in that fact scenario
because you presented a fact scenario in which it's very easy
to agree with that. I think that that doesn't take away the fact
that there could easily be scenarios in which it makes sense
for him to lie about it. >> Yeah. No. So these are the
scenarios in which I think it would make sense to lie about his
motivation. If lying about his motivation were necessary to keep
his children or wife alive or something or healthy or not attacked
or something. uh if lying about his motivation were necessary
in order to prevent um some kind of like
>> it's like a harm equation, right? [clears throat] Does
the lie prevent more harm than it causes?
And unfortunately in in these scenarios with like regards to
Hassan, with regards to Ethan, we've seen demonstration after
demonstration that their well-being is the only thing that matters
to them in the entire world, right? Like they don't really have
principles. They are like narcissistic streamer types who have
massive audiences. They prioritize themselves. Harm done to them
is more important than any harm done to anybody else ever, right?
They can't even. So that's why they're making these decisions
to lie based on, oh well, it hurts me. Well, yeah, it makes you
like look bad to a tiny subset of your audience, but does it
really hurt you? Really? Come on, >> Horrible public policy
or some significantly bad public >> true. if uh lying were
necessary in order to um I don't know to obtain
I don't even [__] know
to
vindicate
larger community interest such as for the protection of the React
community or something. I don't know if if lying about that would
actually cause the React community to be protected. Maybe I could
see some benefit and okay, if you're going to do this lawsuit
anyway, might as well get some benefit out of it. But none of
that exists here. >> Okay. Can I ask you a hypothetical
real
>> What if Ethan Klein wants to get to the mods of some
of these smarter snarker communities or hire people larger than
the people he's suing. And the whole point of these lawsuits
is to get to
>> Is he about to is he about to argue? >> Dig through
their messages and things.
>> There's no way. There's no way that CFKA Esquire is
going to justify doing a little lie to get to Discovery,
right?
The guy who says that the Pixie lawsuit is like entirely baseless.
There's no possible way that that could happen here. It's not
even a remote possibility. I refuse to believe that. That cannot
happen to try to find connections to these people. And if he
comes out and says that, he's worried that some amount of spoliation
might happen to where he'll never be able to find that connection.
And so that's why he's going to lie about his lawsuit motivations
and that's why he's not going to be honest with us about it.
In that hypothetical scenario,
would that be an still you would say that is not an ethical justification?
>> You don't lie. You just don't say
>> That's not a justification that removes
It it gets to the same underlying issue which is you would need
to show that these snarkers are like um some kind of societal
blight in with respect to I understand in the colloquial sense
they're a societal
>> bad bad targets. Okay, they're bad targets. You have
to show they're bad targets so you can use bad tactics against
them >> blight like all Redditors. Okay. What I'm talking
about is the kind of like >> like social concern regarding
like alapone level and all you have right now is um is the the
same kind of underlying malicious siphoning rationale, right?
And so unless you have some kind of purpose related to unless
you can prove your allegations unless you can prove your allegations
against these people that they serve some that they're some kind
of like evil group. Okay.
Unless you improve that, you don't get to do this. You don't
get to like I get to lie to do anything against them because
they're evil. Obviously, CFKA. OBVIOUSLY, CFKA, >> do these
specific actors again, the the mods of this community
um that is
tangibly related to culpable conduct of the type we're looking
for, you're just running into the same problem, which is the
same problem is uh absent some kind of and this is even for the
discovery rationale. Absent some kind of showing of culpability,
um, we're going to want the lawsuit to be tailored the specific
conduct conduct at issue, absent some showing of huge moral fault
of the of the snarkers to the same degree, right, the Redditors
of the as as the streamers. And right now, I'm like I definitely
am seeing intentional malicious siphoning from the the Redditors
or whatever that that is shown. And I always assumed, but you're
just running into the same kind of substantive issue.
But I I would grant if these Redditors were um if these specific
Redditors were encouraging terrorist activity against him, if
they were like um I'm not sure uh attacking
um his family in the real sense, not just in uh criticizing.
If you could show that they um coordinated the CPS call, maybe
you would start to to get there. Show. Show though. Show.
>> No, I do. I just I don't know. I feel like we're g Yeah.
This this feels like on the one hand
there's such a lack of available facts for what we're discussing
or at least my knowledge of the facts that I don't know how I
can engage with that. And two, I think also you just have a much
higher bar when it comes to suing people for outside the norm
of a motive for a lawsuit than me. Mine is very low. >> You
know, mine is low.
>> You just said Alapone. >> No, no, no. You're not
understanding. That's not my standard to sue. You think that's
my standard? >> No. No. That's your standard for suing
with a motive that is outside the intended motives of of the
law fraud. >> So, so, so the alapone thing is that's my
standard for suing when you have no proper purpose, only improper,
right? And only improper purpose and it's collateral to why you're
suing.
Then you have to show some kind of like broader
>> that's in the case in which there's no proper purpose
that so it's it's I do not have a high standard before I going
to think a lawsuit is justified. It's it's a quite forgiving
standard. >> So, do you think that H3 has no proper purpose
in their lawsuit? >> Yeah, I don't think I don't see one
that he actually holds to. There's theoretical ones. So, then
that is your standard that we discussing. >> Well, no.
No. >> Or the H3. >> No, it gets him into the So,
>> there's two boxes, right? >> In the box in which
I think that there's a proper purpose [laughter] and at least
some significant proper purpose, it's actually motivated an individual.
>> The shoes back in the back in general isn't going to
knock it out. Okay. And so absence and showing of societal broader
societal harm, I'm going to assume justified. Okay. Well, that's
in the case in which there's at least a significant proper purpose.
Dude, my community is insane. Okay. This is uncalled for. This
is too much. It's too much. It's this has to stop. It has to
stop. Okay. Somewhere This has to You have to stop doing this
crazy. This is too much. In the case in which there's no significant
proper purpose,
>> please for the love of God, could you just stop
in general? I'm going to assume wrong.
Um, if unrelated to the issues, right, collateral issues, um,
I'm going to assume wrong unless you can show some, uh, predominating
social interest.
You understand that? So in one case the default assumption I'm
going to say is justified unless you can show some societal harm.
And in the case in which there's no significant proper purpose,
I'm going to assume wrong unless you can show some, you know,
predominating social interest in it. >> Does that make
sense? >> And that's what I've been that's why the Hutch
conversation went that way is because I I think that the the
proper purpose is out the window because everyone assumes he
he wants the infringement. He doesn't care about it. He doesn't
care that his property has been infringed. Um he doesn't want
to further deter infringement in that sense. All he wants to
do is target these people because they're these people and he's
lying about his motive. So the only thing left >> Yeah,
Cringle Kesh, you're like super super super far behind on all
of this discussion and saying things that are like categorically
proven to be totally to think, but I don't really have time to
go back and do this with like another person. I hope people in
chat will help you catch up. I guess you've been missing some
of the past couple streams. That's fine. But people in chat,
it's on you. You got to help this guy catch up. relates to whether
there's a a societal interest or moral culpability for these
actors such that we would not preser
>> consider this to be um to be worth it. >> You
understand? It's about where the presumptions are. If I think
that he if I thought he cared about enforcing his copyright in
this instance, >> I would say I have no problem in the
because I assess him not to have that purpose and because I think
that he has basically all improper purposes and because I don't
see the case for overriding moral culpability or social interest,
I'm defaulting to that. I hope that analysis makes sense to you.
>> It does. Okay, I understand your analysis and how you're
doing it. So that means right now to me the difference that I'm
seeing here is that that what I described as there being a pattern
of behavior that he views as putting himself and his business
all stuff up in danger and continuing after the nuke including
but not limited to the CPS go on and the skulls are all his justification
in filing lawsuit whether you me or not we're not going to test
that right now but I'm saying all of that looks to me like a
proper purpose to bring this kind of lawsuit if all of that assumption
that argument that I made is true do you still not believe that
it reaches is a proper purpose. >> No, I don't I don't
think it's a proper >> Okay. Then then second
then as you have said before
there is not a discussion to have because the issue is not to
me
that you know we need to discuss all these different things.
It's that I see there being a proper purpose. You do not. And
so if you don't see there being a proper purpose you're looking
at that second category that he feels there is a threat to his
ability to make money. No, but that's because No, no, no. That's
why we went through all this, right? Like that >> even
less has been walked down like why everybody believes this, right?
Even unless it's been walked through it, he's basically accepted
all of it. He's just coping again in the chat. So, I'm lucky.
Uh, if you want to say that it is not factually proven, conclusively
proven, well, we don't have a brain scan machine that could let
us work as a lie detector. Like, we don't have a PET scan we
could use as a lie detector to see what what Ethan's saying.
But obviously given Ethan's past statements, nothing he's saying
makes any sense, right?
And so when we when we ask like, oh well, how do you square the
circle on these two statements? How do you square the circle
on these things? How do you explain him not doing this or not
doing that if this is his rationale? And even less will like
give you all of that is true. And then he'll go, this is based
on vibes. Instead of admitting that it's based on just logical
deductions,
he'll go, oh, it's actually like vibes.
>> A subjective belief of financial threat. Okay. Yes.
>> In in the main >> Yeah. Yeah. This is basically
what people say and we've spent like three days explaining to
people why this is. So I again people in check can educate you
if you like. >> We're not going to say that's a proper
purpose for a lawsuit that isn't related to that. So the example
I gave was >> that is the entire point of an IP lawsuit
is to protect your ability to make money >> related related
related to the infringement related to your works.
>> Not related to criticism. And I gave you the example
of a a person who only motivation was to sign.
Okay, hang on a second. So let's let's just deal with it. Right.
Ethan wasn't under threat financially from infringement, right?
>> Um my understanding is well actually yes, he was. >> In
what respect >> was it significant? Was it significant?
>> He was not under threat. No infringement or no? >> He
literally suffered.
>> That isn't what we're talking about. that I mean that's
true of any if that is his actual scale
or any large part of his argument then his actions make no sense.
You cannot defend the idea that financial
um financial harm from copyright infringement is a significant
portion of his rationale when all of the most
like degenerate and large actors are given like a total pass.
Oh, I don't want to kill you guys at all. Right. That's obviously
true. >> That's true of anybody. No, no, no. I'm saying
it's beyond a threat. It is no longer a threat. He was materially
harmed by their action. >> No, but he he wasn't his financial
security wasn't wasn't threatened by the >> Security. Sure.
That's not what we were talking about. We were talking about
whether or not he was threatened and then I said he was materially
harmed. That's what I said. I said he was his >> Um, how
do you explain the concept and law of the empty chair? Wait,
the classic example is a hospital being sued in a medical malpractice
suit lawsuit against an ER doctor. Wait, Sean, you understand
exactly why the hospital would have, even if it's ancillary responsibility,
why they're liable in that case, right? I don't have to explain
to you why a hospital might be liable for employing a doctor,
right? I don't have to explain to you why a hospital might be
liable to hold their doctors to account, might be liable for
enforcing standards on their doctors,
right? Okay, sure. All right, fair enough. Then can you explain
to me how it connects to this?
what you just said. So you just said here that was the classic
example and now you say for sure weak example.
Is it the classic example or is it a weak example? Cuz I'm guessing
as soon as you get anywhere near the point where the the empty
chair person
is actually unrelated, it's very easy for that person to get
out of it.
>> Was the difference. That's why I saying you can debate
whether or not the significance of it. Um but he did suffer harm
to him. >> Yeah. Yeah, that's just basically saying any
infringement is by definition justified. Any copyright law is
>> I thought we agree that's not true. >> I I think
that I think that the as we said, there are very remote scenarios
in which that it it could not be true. But as I said at the very
beginning of this, 99% of the times I would say that it is ethical.
So I barely I want to hear you say it. I want to hear you say
it. If Hassan sues loner box for copyright, you're gonna say
that that's good. >> I would say that that is an ethical
action. I don't I would say that it was like good. You just set
out a standard and the minute I give you something that applies
to a lib, you're not applying your own standard you just set.
>> You mean what? What? What was Hassan? Why is Hassan
not ethical in enforcing his copyright against Lbox? I don't
understand that. >> No, you you just said I I I don't know.
You did you say that it would be good for Hassan to do lumber
box? >> It would be ethical. >> Would it be good?
Ethical. Yes, ethical. These are all >> I don't I don't
view I don't ethical and good as being a synonymous word. I don't
I don't use >> I think that's when you know whenever you
say this. Well, is do you mean good or morally good? Do you mean
bad or morally bad? As soon as you utter these words in a conversation
on the internet, you know for a fact your is the diameter of
a tennis ball. Okay. Has the diameter of a tennis ball. The second
you say that you you can just basically that is the equivalent
statement. Okay. Um I don't think do you mean morally good or
just good? Your has the diameter of a tennis ball. Those are
the same you that is what you just said. Like you you no
You no longer have
control of your colon. Okay, it's over. That's basically what
just happened.
I'll let you draw your own conclusions, >> Okay. Wait,
wait. Okay, so whatever we're applying to Ethan here, let's apply
to this case. So, do you think that Ethan's lawsuits are good?
I don't I I don't I think that they are ethical good. I don't
know. I mean, like, if we're going to just use them synonymously,
sure they're good in that. >> No, what you mean? You're
the one who brought up this distinction. So, do you >> I
I don't I don't think I would. >> Yeah. I I don't know
if I would I would put a good or bad label on it as how I use
this. >> So, I'll ask you, do you have a do you have a
view about whether Ethan's lawsuits are good?
>> No. I think that good is a broad term and that ethical
is a precise term. So, I would rather use a more precise term.
I don't think good is a word good word to use because it brings
in a bunch of normative loading that I would not want to put
onto >> I don't think that Ethan is a good person. I don't
think that the people he's suing are good people. >> No,
I don't. But I want to say if I use the word good, it implies
that there is a good person involved here and I don't want to
make that implication. I want to talk about the specific action
of this person whether or not it's ethical or not. That's why
I'm using a precise term. I'm telling you why I'm using the word
differently than just as a pure synonym for good or bad. Okay,
that's why I'm doing so. >> So, so if someone said that
Kafka thought that the lawsuits were good, that wouldn't be true
because you don't have a view on that. >> That would you
correct. It would not be a correct sentence. I think they're
good >> But it would be accurate to say that Kafka thought
that the lawsuits were
>> Yes. Okay. Um by which you mean morally >> Sure.
For the sake of this conversation, I will go along with that.
dude,
like, how are these people not embarrassed? I just don't Where's
the shame? Where's the shame?
There's no shame. You You should feel shame. You should feel
truly deep and
reverberating shame for saying these things, for saying things
like this. It is actually
>> That I don't like using the word moral that way, but
mean morally ethical. >> In what other sense would it be
ethical? I hope what I'm trying to avoid is a notion that that
you're just pricing in like ethical under the rules of professional
conduct. That's what I'm trying to avoid. >> No, no, that
I mean I would say they're morally ethical in the sense that
like I don't think that they violate any moral wrong. I don't
think there's any moral wrong that exists here and therefore
they would be morally ethical. I guess we can say I don't think
there's any moral violations happening here. So I guess it would
therefore kind of default into a moral ethical
>> if there's a difference right [clears throat] because
something could be um >> neutral. Is he trying to say that
when he says it's ethical it's neutral
dude this this language game that he's just invented like a language
game in the past 10 seconds that is totally like out to lunch
>> ethically acceptable.
>> Uh again um we're saying he's morally wrong and legally
right. If you try to if you just try to differentiate
again, you're you're like really struggling, right? So like morally
he's in the wrong. Nobody's arguing he can't file the lawsuit.
Like that's that's already decided and nobody fought on this.
If you're interpreting that people are saying he shouldn't he
he can't file this lawsuit like legally it's just wrong to file
this lawsuit. If you've interpreted anybody saying that through
any of the content we've done in the past like 3 weeks, I truly
don't know what to tell you cuz this has been litigated like
at least a hundred times. But yeah, nobody's saying you can't
file the lawsuit, so he's just All right, I guess. Yeah, he's
just he's like a bad person. Yep.
Yeah. If you're just like, I like bad people and I don't care
when they do bad things. I don't know why you watch content that's
basically only us talking about people's like moral culpability.
That's like what all the drama content is is just talking about
people who are bad and judging them. So, it's kind of weird that
you're like, "Oh, well, he's just bad." Yeah, that's like the
whole point of the channel. cover a bunch of people who do like
bad bad people doing bad and laugh at them, mock them, what >> and
ethically not acceptable, right? >> So just when we call
Ethan Klein like a totally spineless,
a totally spineless who can't stand on business and fight back
and and has to take on the weakest people he can because when
he actually fights a real bully on the internet, he gets slapped.
He gets totally by whatever bully he tries to go after. Okay,
so he's a tiny pathetic
If you get upset at that or you think that that's not true, I
would just ask why. Because that's exactly what we're talking
about here.
>> And you're on the view that it's ethically acceptable.
>> Yeah. There's no undercurrent of that. That's never
existed anywhere here, right? That's literally never existed
anywhere here at all. The undercurrent of whether this stuff
should be like should be litigated. Okay. Morally, it's wrong
to file the lawsuit. I'm going to judge you for filing the lawsuit.
Whether it can be litigated like should should that's like an
oughtu ought it ought be litigated what society should be yes
but whether or not it can be litigated is not being cons discussed
those are different concepts
>> yeah yes >> and you would also say just real quick
just small small very very small comment real quick I view discussions
of morality to basically be like a presuppositional thing that's
just super personal that creates a that you're always going to
be using a ton of personal language and they are cancer for discussions.
So I just really don't like to talk about very much. So like
my apprehension comes there. It's fine discussion language. That's
where my apprehension
I don't mind talking but morality is just >> wait you take
a view on ethics morals. >> Every time you talk about >> ethics
I do morals I have a very hard time discussing with people is
what I'm saying. Ethics are fine. Morals are something that I
feel like you get into theology. You get into a lot of presuppositionalism.
You get a lot of weird personal language that I think is not
very helpful to discussion. I think ethics are a little bit more
easier to discuss because they're more about the interpersonal
nature of of actions and how they affect people and how they
affect society as a whole. I think ethics has more to do with
that whereas morality has a more internalized and personalized
view of the world that can really get into some sticky territory
that has a hard time aligning with each other even though we
might have these extractions that look like they are the same.
You get just tied up into
>> Listen, when I sound discussing morality, I think that's
cuz everyone sounds discussing morality
>> tangents that no one cares about. Sorry. So, so >> that's
why I don't like talking about >> If if you're saying something
is unethical, it's not equivalent to saying it's immoral, right?
Something could be unethical and moral.
>> Something could be unethical and moral. I think that
is possible. Yes. >> Can you think of a single example
of something that's unethical and moral?
>> Um, yes. I think speaking up at a uh hearing in which
a man is about to be accused of >> No, but that's equivocation.
That's equivocation because then it's >> that's an explicit
that I think it is moral to stand up and say that. I don't think
it is necessarily ethical to do that. No, because the ethics
there, this is what I'm concerned about. That's I'm concerned
about that equivocation. The equivocation is between something
ethical in the sense of oughts and ought not and ethical in the
sense of rules of professional conduct. That's what I'm trying
to avoid. I'm trying to avoid that confusion by by using a set
of nomenclature that makes it clear that what we're talking about
aren't the rules of professional conduct, but have to do with
um our sense of right and
>> Pisco is debating CFKA Esquire,
the Pisco replacement. Pisco is basically taking his replacement
and
him out of existence. Okay, this is the CF gas esquire guy from
DG the lawyer guy. He uh he's getting completely obliterated.
He's getting torn apart bit by bit. Not a good showing for him.
Um for some reason nobody could seem to do this. Nobody could
seem to thread this needle where they don't sound talking episcal
on this subject. >> Okay. If we want to only talk about
things that are like purely right and wrong outside of kind of
these these other ethical considerations you described, that's
fine. I wouldn't really take a position on that about this law
this lawsuit. Oh, >> I don't think that this lawsuit has
a real moral consideration for me. I don't I wouldn't think about
it really in those terms. >> Oh, so you have the view that
you don't have a view on the underlying rightness or wrongness
from a moral perspective on the lawsuits.
>> I think that without I think that that I could receive
enough effects to have that at this point. I probably wouldn't.
No. But in yeah like at best I would say that the most I would
say is I don't think that H3 is committing immoral >> Why
would you wait why would you come in and talk to Pisco
about this issue when the entire reason he's been having these
conversations is about morally decrying Ethan for filing the
lawsuits.
Nobody's confused about what the topic is when you come to debate
Piscll on this. Bro, your avatar is tweaking. Is it tweaking?
Wait, why is it tweaking? I don't know why it's tweaking. Okay,
whatever. Um, yeah, you literally know what the topic is. Like,
it's the same topic. It always >> wrong by bringing these
lawsuits, >> but also I believe I believe I believe >> Wait,
no, baby. You can't say that, can you? You said you don't have
>> I believe I believe that morally neutral actions are
possible. I I believe it can be right, wrong, or morally. >> So,
you do have a view on the moral action. You think it's morally
neutral. >> Well, that's what I've been saying. I wouldn't
I wouldn't create like a moral distinction of like good or bad
on it. I would keep it more like it's just morally neutral.
>> Okay. Okay. And it's morally neutral because he has
at least some plausible it's a legally valid claim for which
there can be some compensation. Therefore, it's morally neutral.
That's all it takes. >> Um, I think that
now when Zip Zip tried to make this exact claim in a conversation
with Pisco, Pisco literally tore his arms off and beat him to
death with his own arms. Okay. It was very disturbing to listen
to. Let's see if Kfka can avoid this exact trap.
All right. We'll see if it can happen. >> Some compensation.
Therefore, it's more >> Avoid this precise trap. >> Um
I think that that's the vast majority of it. Yeah. Because I
think that the moral question for me would be like, are you abusing
the system to harm people or for your own benefit that you shouldn't
do? I think that's a moral question that I would be answering
there. >> Yeah. I think that that is exactly my point is
we that's why looking at purposes and and and uh reasons and
intentions. That's what I'm trying to do. But you're saying like,
"Oh, well, it meets this threshold of plausibility with respect
to the claim." And you know, some
>> Yeah. When when Zip Zip made this claim, Pisco basically
was like a Wookie. Like a raging
8 foot tall hairy ape that tore Zip Zip's arms out of their sockets
and then started windmilling with them. Okay? Like he was General
Grievous. He started windmilling. I'm doing all all Star Wars
metaphors for Pisco just in case he watches this. Okay? started
windmilling his [__] arms around and beat him to
death with his own arms. It was crazy. >> Trivial amount
or at least I don't know some nominal amount of harm done and
therefore it's morally neutral and nothing I do in terms of purposes
and intent gets you over the line the other >> Yeah.
Not nothing. There are and there are scenarios which you could.
It's just they're very remote. They're very hard to bring in
and show I like it's
>> I've just never seen I don't I've ever seen a lawsuit
like that actually. Well,
>> have currently experiencing
>> Damn, man. >> I mean, is it is it your experience
that this is like a super common thing that we should always
be considering it and worried about this as a thing? Cuz like
I don't know. I haven't
>> I think people consider the law the morality of bringing
lawsuits. They always do that. If you in every lawsuit that's
like major, people talk about like is this right? You know, think
about the defamation lawsuit uh with Amber Heard. It was so okay.
>> It wasn't [clears throat] just legal. It was ethics,
>> about just desserts, about justice, about who deserves.
>> Okay, same thing with Kyle Writtenhouse. It wasn't just
>> a legal answer. That's important for >> But it's
not only about that. It's ethics. People say, you know, that
lawsuit that Sorry, that indictment. >> This is just wrong.
This is just wrong. You want to argue this stuff? By the way,
go to Queensman's chat and tell him that he's you're on great
joy. He's going to he's going to lose it. Oh, is that like from
SOME FED AH
BOOMERS? um is based on like fundamental morale. I mean, think
also about the Leticia James case and the Comey case. I mean,
the grand jury actually did charge Omi with um in that first
attempt. Now, there were other legal issues. >> Um and
likewise in the Leticia James, the sandwich thrower, right? You
think the sandwich thrower indictment was correct? I'll give
you this example, right? The sandwich thrower threw a sandwich
at a cop under then existing um and the current existing assault
laws. It doesn't take a lot for you to get to offensive touching
against an officer and the exercises of their duties. Such for
me it's just kind of trivial that throwing a sandwich at an officer
when they're doing their duties uh would constitute assault.
Okay. And so there's a more than plausible claim. >> I
think Connor made himself the old lady
from the from the Martell's.
I forget her name. Alinda Elena. Alena
>> to bring against the sandwich tower. Was that the right
decision to bring that
>> Pisco. Pisco was originally going to be Brandon Stark
who gets like burned by the mad king and then I think he made
a friendly for some reason. >> Moral consideration >> from
a moral consideration >> probably because Pisco and I are
brothers. That's probably why
>> he threw the sandwich at >> this with this in
this administration. I'd probably say no. In other administrations,
possibly yes. Like if it happened under the Biden administration
and there was some officer they got a sandwich throw the lawsuit.
Never mind. >> Dude, Pisco is desperately, desperately
trying to extract generalizable rules from this guy and this
guy's like, "No, I like I like just injecting my subjective experience
all the time. I like the law to be as biased as possible." Actually,
I like really, really, really biased laws. As biased as possible.
I love bias. >> Is it kind of stupid to bring a felony
case for the [__] sandwich?
>> It might feel that way. Well, like for Trump and them,
yeah, it does because I think that in in the scenario in which
that sandwich was thrown,
yeah, that was like a scenario of their own making. like they're
they're abusing their powers. These things this kind of stuff.
>> But there's a valid but there's a valid
there's a valid legal claim. There was some I mean what you don't
you want to
>> Wait, Kango Kesh I just there it is. Isn't it kind of
stupid to bring the case? Yes, we're saying it's morally wrong
to bring the case. Wait wait wait. So it's very clear you can
bring it.
Like, is it
morally is it legally ethical to call someone the hard to their
face in public in front of their
Okay. Does that mean it's does that mean it's uh
like you can do that legally? Does that mean it's morally good?
No. These things are disconnected. They're completely disconnected.
Right? You can say something is bad, you shouldn't do it, and
also admit that somebody can legally do it. like vice versa.
You can admit that something is legally possible legally like
possible to do or that you Yeah. And then it's morally bad. Those
two things they they exist disjoint from each other. They happen
to overlap, but they have disconnects at the margins that you
have to deal with. And that's what Pisco is doing. It's your
sandwich throwers. Well, you going to just throw condiments on
all of our [__]
>> in these scenarios, I think it's appropriate. Um, in
other scenarios, it might not be and it might not be >> What
about the Judge Dugan case?
>> Well, you and I disagree on that case.
You I'm I am pro Dugan. You are >> I'm not anti Dugan in
this. I don't think they should have charged her.
>> I just have a different take on the legal some of the
doctrines like the judicial immunity stuff. >> Oh, I see
what you're saying. >> Yeah, but like I don't think >> you
definitely disagree on that. >> She definitely tried she
tried to obstruct that administrative warrant. You're not going
to make a good argument. She didn't.
>> Can't I can't see in her mind. She's a judge. Her thoughts
are beyond me. Dude, why are you buying these like [laughter]
level one arguments from the people who say, "PCO, you can't
read mind, so we can't do intent." You know that's stupid. Whenever
they say that, >> it's true. Everyone judges, you know,
judges are just they're too smart for the rest of >> those
are level one arguments, CFKA. >> No,
because I mean, no, no, no. I mean, like again, if we this is
this is a matter of administration. If we were in if we were
in a B administration, yeah, sure, charge that.
>> Like, [clears throat] dude, he's just >> whatever.
But in Trump,
>> I kind of view how you do did just did that. And listen,
I will definitely put some um like extra sauce in the Trump lazy
top. Okay. Because I think but the reason is why do I put so
much negative inferences on Trump lawsuits and Trump indictments?
Why why do you think I do
>> Because they're abusing. >> Because of the purpose.
Because of the intent, right? Why is Trump trying to do what
he's trying to do with like the universities? He's trying to
silence opposition and know even though he might have a like
uh collaboration with the universities, he might have a valid
claim to to stop the funding of the universities, right? He might
have a valid claim to to like in initiate monopoly actions and
stop monopoly actions against some of these tech firms. Notwithstanding
the the validity there, it's the purpose. It's the motive. It's
the intent. I'm going to take that like what are you trying to
do? What are you trying to actualize? What is your perfect world?
That's going to do a lot of heavy lifting for me. And that's
why I take such a negative inference on what Trump is doing all
the time with this [__] And I would apply that
to the benefit of libs all over all over because I
if some
tanky socialist some kind of loser who who believes that we ought
to be a Marxist society, some Hassan fan tries to lean on libs.
Do you think I'm going to be on their side? >> I don't
think so. I don't know. I haven't seen evidence of that. And
when when that day comes, when that day comes when I stand shoulder-to-shoulder
with libs, I want it to be principled. I think people need to
be principled.
And maybe that's not >> Wait, who is Destiny? Destiny was
uh the mad king. Destiny is the mad king burning people at the
stake.
>> That's what I want. >> I've always said that about
you. I've always known that about you, but you discussed it for
sure. And I think that like I don't I don't know if I see
any like I don't know. I've never been like against you on your
position on the H3 stuff. I think it's finally you're discussing
it and you want to have the conversation with everybody, but
I've never like been like
>> You brought it up. >> You might just disagree.
>> No, but you brought it up in the context of your podcast.
This is why this just came up, by the way. We're relapsing into
it because I heard what you guys were saying. You're like, I'll
never judge or I'll very seldom char like judge the ethics of
a lawsuit. And I just think that that is so wrong-headed. I understand
the legal part of it is super important. I don't doubt I love
the legal part of it and that is so juicy and good and we need
to have that 100%. But like we can never turn on turn off our
ethics brain. Ethics always has to be on. Okay. It always has
to be on because the minute we drop it, I think we're hypocrites.
We we can't do that. We have to always have a framework. >> I
think that's like a fair Yeah, that's that's fair. I understand
where you're coming from on that. And like if if we were in Camala
Harris's presidency,
>> you sound like a mega. >> That that is a genuine
That is just a genuine mispronunciation. If we were in the Harris
presidency right now, um >> you don't trust yourself. >> You
start talking to I know because I No, no, because I genu that's
why that's how you know it's a genuine misspe and not trying
to be mean to her because I like her. Um but if if this was a
Harris presidency I at this point would you know please go it's
great that you think that way but you know we have a system and
we can exist in a system where ethics are kind of the going way
of doing things and while there might be times we do need this
consideration um you know I'm going to you know I'm going to
probably default to just assuming things are ethical.
However, in our current system you are of course right and and
I think that is totally something to keep in mind. This is this
is like the Biden rose glasses too. Like I'm a Biden stand. I
[__] with his administration in a major way. But
like I get so much for criticizing the pardons. I get so much
for uh um well actually I stand by American so I get for that.
But like I get for talking bad about uh Biden immigration stuff.
So >> this isn't just a woy w me.
I think I think you need to keep them honest because like when
they don't you have someone like Bill Clinton >> and Bill
Clinton he I don't know like how he kind of mesmerized a bunch
of Democrats into like accepting
bad conduct lying on like under oath like that the whole scandals.
Now I know a lot of there was a witch hunt surely but he definitely
did stuff that I think was impeachable. That's Bill Clinton and
uh and yeah so like I just don't think that we can ever um because
that's and we're no better in many ways than MAGA. If you just
say like should morality of the >> what the [__]
Democrats are in office. That's like what the Magnus people >> People
linking me >> clips. I would have probably felt that way,
man. >> I wasn't a lawyer at the time and I wasn't aware
of nothing. But like I would probably say I feel the same way
in like under Bush or under, you know, a Republican. THAT'S NOT
I PROBABLY HAVE
NO NO
GEORGE W. BUSH. >> NO,
NO. Why Why do you assume in the George W. Bush era just like
trust that ethics are happening in government, bro? You don't
believe that?
>> Yeah. Uh, no I do because again it's the it's the default
belief with Trump. I default believe do not believe that he's
acting ethically >> in George Bush one I would have the
default belief that now I can see things because I'm
again I'm not super aware of what was going around on then I
was kind of during that era and I wasn't really paying attention
to legal. So maybe there's a whole lot of things where I >> is
Pisco arguing you I think Pisco is just arguing you you be wary
at all >> should not have that view but I feel like if
I was if there was any Republican president that wasn't Trump
I would probably have a lot more
grace or at least default be like all right let's just like go
into this assuming it's true and if it turns out not where with
Trump I'm saying no I'm not giving you the benefit of the doubt
you need to show me that this is >> I think you should
always be skeptical of government yeah okay
>> I think it's fine to be skeptical of government that's
not really talk about here, whether I'm going to have to give
them the benefit of the doubt of whether or not this is an ethical
thing. I think it's generally a good idea to have a benefit of
the doubt. This is an ethical thing. You can be suspicious, you
can be skeptical, that stuff. I think outside of the Trump administrations,
it makes sense. But then the Trump administrations makes sense.
>> They're kind of like
right now. I don't really want to I this might be discuss whatever
Trump does. I mean, that >> um I want to move on. >> That's
all you're saying. And that's different than other presidents.
>> Yeah. Kind that's that's fine. We can we can put it
at that. It's more of like what are these people doing with the
power they have? What what's the government doing here? What
are they trying to do with it? And do I trust Yeah. Do I trust
what they're doing? Yes or no? I don't really trust Trump with
it. You know, I like I'm not going to see like if I like I'm
not believing that things are ethical to the point that I'm not
even like that. I'm just going to like ignore evidence of them
being unethical, right? >> I'm not ignoring things, but
I'm just sitting here. I'm not saying that like there's a threshold
that needs to be met and then okay, now I think something's ethical,
right? I think it's I think it's appropriate to assume, okay,
Ethan Klein has brought this lawsuit and it's he's got a legal
claim and there's an ethical re like it is by default ethical
for him to bring it. >> Why? Now, I don't see why not why
would I why would I not like why am I suspicing having so much
suspicion of a private actor bringing a lawsuit against other
private actors who have acted in a way that impose liability
upon them for their behavior? Why would I >> basically
asking like okay if you have a reason to look into it and I feel
like
>> you generally you started this conver saying you like
you generally trust me on constitutional issues you don't think
I'm stupid right >> I do not >> don't you think that
the fact that I'm talking right now someone who is li that I'm
liberal I am a capitalist always be a capitalist not going to
be a socialist socialist all right I said >> I don't think
I don't think there's any kind of ideologically ideologically
>> so so gay that he has to do these signals it's just
gay it's so gay I'm sorry. It's so stupid. Like, I'm fine with
that position. It's just gay that he feels like he has to say
socialism to like make people stop reading him. >> Given
that I said it, >> doesn't the fact that I said it give
you some reason to look into it?
>> I mean, it gives you reason to like have this discussion
with you, >> but like as far as the >> I don't think
I could like I'm walking away from this conversation. I don't
know what your opinion is. I couldn't summarize it.
>> The the feeling is mutual. Uh >> you don't feel
like you could summarize my opinion? No, I don't know why you
think H3's lawsuit is unethical. >> I don't
>> don't mean that necessarily. >> I will try on
multiple levels. I don't >> Okay. So, I will try to concisely
say why I think it's unjustified. Okay.
>> Notwithstanding what I think it is. >> So, I think
Pesco is going to sum up his position and he's going to ask what
part of that did you not understand >> legal validity that
Ethan Klein copyright lawsuits. I think that the predominating
influences, improper purposes, that is to say, spiked and uh
going after people for the purpose of damaging them personally,
that the presence of those motives and the total lack of presence
of proper motives under the copyright statute uh cause this to
be bad and there are no overriding uh sets of moral culpability
or uh social goodness to compensate for that fundamental lack
of proper purpose. That make sense? >> Okay. Okay, that
makes sense. >> Okay. Now, let me give you mine. I think
that Ethan Klein felt like >> uh Oh, hold on. >> Copyright
statute. That is to say, >> I have to go back and listen
[clears throat] again. Sorry, I I checked a message legal validity
with the Ethan. >> I got to listen again. I'm sorry, guys.
You got to listen one more time. I think that the predominating
influences, improper purposes, that is to say spiked and uh going
after people for the purpose of damaging them personally, that
the presence of those motives and the total lack of presence
of proper motives under the copyright statute uh cause this to
be bad and there are no overriding uh sets of moral culpability
or uh social goodness to compensate for that fundamental lack
of proper purpose. That make sense? >> Okay. Okay, that
makes sense. >> Okay. Now, let me give you mine. I think
>> dude, I wish I wish Pisco would have said what part
of that was unclear from previous discussions you've watched
from from me on this and the current conversation we had. Which
part of that did you not get? Cuz you said you couldn't summarize
my position. So, is there any part of that you felt I didn't
communicate to you? >> That Ethan Klein felt like there
was some kind of danger to himself, his family, his reputation,
and his ability to make money doing what he does by these people.
that continued past the point at which he set a trap for them
to impose liability. And then he used this lawsuit to sue those
people that he thought was putting him in danger. And I think
that that is similar enough to an IP lawsuit's goal that it really
doesn't bring in an ethical question or an ethical like negative
here. >> Which IP? >> He doesn't believe this. He
can't possibly believe
>> of being able to maintain your ability to make money
in the market >> with respect. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
with respect to copyrightable. >> I don't share that. No,
I don't think I'm telling you. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Like um seat belt like seat belt bylaws and murder
laws have the same goal. Keeping you alive. That's why I think
brother
brother wait
no no no. Stop. This is no. This is so insane. So you think that
you think that a purpose of a copyright statute is to protect
people from financial harm unrelated to copyrightable works?
>> No. I think that has a purpose. I'm saying that this
is close enough in purpose to me. He's saying this person is
is acting. >> Isn't like how the law is tailored like the
the specificity of it not incredibly important. Like there's
no category >> I'm going to go after them because they're
harming me, right? Whether that's because of the IP or not, that's
fine. I am okay if someone is saying there's another harm that
is motivating me to do this. Now if that other harm is like this
person cheated on me >> like a relationship I would say
like that's yeah that's why this is a different kind virtue of
what >> of a different
>> Sure. Cringo Kish you want to prove to me how Denim's
had massive amounts of spice spite while infringing on his copyright.
Is that because she read one message where somebody said hey
are you watching this here cuz I don't want to give him a view
and she was like yeah I'm going to stream it. Is that where she
show showed
a massive amounts of the spite is born out of the malice and
Oh, sorry. You're saying what if his spite is born out of this?
Oh, no. That's uh that's actually totally wrong, Cringle Kesh,
because the malice and spite that led to him making the trap
to registering the copyright happened before they made any of
those statements. Sorry. Like, you are totally getting it backwards.
Completely backwards here. Okay. You actually don't understand,
you know, time and the linear progression of it. >> Wait,
no. Virtue of what? That's perfect. I mean, you just get >> I
don't think there's a mon I don't think there's a market here.
I don't think there's a monetary issue. >> Wait, wait,
wait, wait. No, this No, no. This person This person was cheated
on. This person or was abused or whatever it was in the relation.
>> Yeah. Some interpersonal stuff and they It's um psychological.
>> Nope. I don't think Pisco has ever said these cases
are legally lacking. He's always said it's very likely that Ethan
prevails in all of them. That's just an outright lie. Just an
outright lie. Read my message backwards.
Wait, but once I read it correctly, I Sorry. I I was going to
say I was going to say something else and then I read the message
and then I just pointed out how you were wrong. Okay, he just
said it. Legally lacking. Hold on. >> Like a relationship.
I would [clears throat] say like that's Yeah, that's why is it
different? >> In virtue of what? >> Of a different
kind. >> Wait, no. In virtue of what? That's perfect. I
mean, you just >> I don't think there's a mon I don't think
there's a market here. I think there's a monetary issue. >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait. No. No. No. This person This person was cheated
on. This person or was abused or whatever it was in relation.
>> Yeah. some interpersonal stuff and they it's um psychological
damage in virtue of what would that lawsuit be
>> Well, didn't go back. >> I think I think the nature
of the interpersonal nature of the fact that it is of it is not
this kind of thing that's affecting his >> right. So, if
it's not related to money,
>> Um that and the interpersonal nature of it, both of
them.
>> Okay. So, now you agree, don't you, that this lawsuit,
Ethan says, is not about money at all. It's not about making
>> He said that. >> Well, like he's not it's not
about making money off the lawsuit. Sure. >> No, it's not
it's not about damages. It's not about money. You said that >> it's
not about making money off a
>> Uh you can go grab the time stamp if you want. Even
last year, I I can't get it right now. >> Yes, that's how
I take >> um I'm guessing if he said it's it's lacking,
is going to be an intent, but we can just find it later with
the transcript. I don't I It's so discordant with what Pisco
said in the past that I just don't believe so. But right now,
it's minus hour 29 if you want to go grab it. Minus hour 29.
But you have to go grab it fast cuz um that's going to change,
right, with the negative time stamps cuz he's live streaming.
that that sounds to me like
lost it. Sure. >> Yeah. So, it's not about putting him
in a better financial position. That's on all fours with your
example. >> No, no, no. Him making money.
>> Wait, so when you said that Ethan believes that he's
been harmed, that this threatens his like his business, and then
he says this is not about damages or money, that sort of like
totally categorically proves you incorrect, right? No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. It doesn't. No, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. No.
lawsuit [laughter] position. Him showing people that he will
rat you if you go after him. >> No, but that's not his
purpose either. >> No, that's not his.
>> Why? How was that, >> Dude? That's like a whole
Catherine just opened a whole thing. He just said rat. What is
rat? It's totally unethical behavior with the for the purpose
of destroying somebody else's credibility or livelihood, right?
Like he just used a word that means doing something bad to harm
someone else with no like no there's no positive there's no moral
version of rap, right? And he's like, "Well, he has to totally
morally like cut this person's head off to show that if anybody
wants to criticize him in the future, that that could happen."
Dude, you're waiting. >> Why is he talking about public?
>> Wait a second. Wait a second. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh KFKA is so dumb, dude. This guy is so dumb,
bro. He's >> Hitler in the petition. >> Wait, wait,
wait, wait. No, because it's not motivated by uh the copyright
statute and it's motivated by other stuff. That's why he put
the Hitler in the picture. It answers itself. Your question answers
itself. But why is uh the kind of deterrence that he's doing
by the copyright infringement um lawsuit in the context of the
interpersonal uh situation between the boyfriend and the girlfriend,
why is that like well I'm trying to deter future cheating. I'm
trying to deter future um misconduct within within relationships.
Why is that not the same thing? I don't want them to rat [__]
me in the context of a
>> I don't think that an IP infringement is related to
the type of harm that results from a person. [laughter]
Wasn't the whole reason Pisco brought this ancillary example
up, wasn't the whole reason to say that like obviously things
have to be related to copyright to be like relevant to the law
like like the lawsuit's purpose has to be about infring like
enforcing your copyright. I feel like Pisco just worked it backwards.
So now CFKA is saying no no it's not the same because uh I don't
think a copyright lawsuit is the same. Copyright lawsuits is
like a class of its own. Yeah, that was his >> Okay, we're
almost there. We're almost there. So that what you're saying
is that the disconnect between what IP is designed to do and
the motive behind the lawsuit is factoring into your analysis.
That's what you just said.
>> So if someone is not actually motivated by the cognizable
interest recognized under the copyright statute, that is to say,
dealing with infringement, dealing with artistic licenses, dealing
with uh trying to protect your work, dealing with recovering
damages, dealing with deterring future infringement. If none
of those interestes are activated, we would tend to see a problem
just like in your example. Okay. Relationships. This is the copyright
statute is not here to vindicate relation. >> Dude, he
just that was that was something else right there. That was something
else. Okay. >> No, it's it's here to vindicate infringes
on on a copyright.
>> Yeah. Which he's doing. And
he's doing it to make sure other people don't [__]
with him and his ability to make money. >> It's a golem.
We just We've just hit a golem reset. We need a soundboard for
golem resets. Okay, we need like a clockwork soldier getting
wound back up. Like their their joints are all cracking. They're
being wound back up. He just got totally totally blown out. And
he doesn't realize it. And he just goes back to restating his
positive opinion instead of disagreeing with Pisco. That's how
you know somebody's wrong. They go, "Well, I don't have a disagreement
with what you just said, but I'm going to restate my opinion
from the ground up because I think I just got ripped and I can't
help it, but I'm just going to restate it. We're going to reset
the whole conversation." No. No, he's not. No, he's not [__]
worthy. >> Wait, no, no, no. He's not. >> You don't
think so? >> You think he's doing this? >> You don't
think there's any economic harm that's come to him by this >> That's
not what I said. No, no, no, but but that's not what >> I'm
just asking a question. >> No, but hang on. So, I think
that there's probably some in terms of they stopped watching
his his content and have uh said bad things about him, which
has probably caused subscriber
caused the end of his podcast. >> No, but but that's that's
not the sort of economic harm that is vindicated by the copyright
statute. Agreed.
>> Right. So it's not >> but it doesn't mean that
he can't get that value out of it. >> I'm not asking whether
he can get that value out of it. The question is whether I mean
he the the example that you used the relationship they could
get the relationship uh vindicating value out of that lawsuit.
So it doesn't help. >> It's not unethical for him to get
that out of it. How's that unethical? >> No, that's the
whole thing we're talking about, right? So we're trying to that's
begging the question, right? The whole question is is it ethical
in the context of the relationship copyright infringement? you
said it's unethical in virtue of the lack the mismatch between
the purpose of the lawsuit in the context of the relationship
dispute and the purpose of the IP statute and that was enough
for you to say this is wrong in this context the same logic should
apply and so you should compare the rational agree I think yes
I know >> that was your logic >> I view I have a
feeling this is going to come down to even less if you're watching
he's about to pull a page out of your book he's going to go well
relationship stuff is relationship stuff is just different and
weird it's like different and weird and I don't think you could
put it in the same the harm that is being done to him to be in
a kind with IP issues. There's a market forces because there
is issues of market actors and non-market actors and how they
are acting and what they are doing in a way that harms your ability
to act >> which market wait which market >> his ability
to live stream and make money as a streamer.
>> I I them are harming his ability to do that with the
snark people. They did it one by infranchise IP admitted it too.
>> You were right. He said lack of fundamental proper p
purpose under the copyright statute. Okay. Yeah. referring to
his motives
and uh this guy did not use the same excuse you used. He used
some of those >> two by all of the other and that's what
he views and you can't get to them for all that other because
it's protected in a lot of ways. Oh, you know what? They're going
to go after you in a nonprotected way. And guess what? I'm going
to make sure everybody knows that the way I'm doing this is not
just because of this. It's because if I could, I would sue them
for this other [__] but I can't. So, I'm going to
use this to one go after the thing that it says and for the other
stuff. And if everybody else tries this, guess what? I'm going
to do the same to you. I'm trying to see I'm trying to understand
the the disanalogy here. Okay. I'm trying to understand the disalogy.
You get me? >> So you're saying the disanalogy between
the relationship
>> cringle kesh. If you want to actually argue this, I'm
probably going to stop paying attention to your chats. If you
want to argue this, you can hop in the >> And the case
in which we're talking about has to do with well there's just
no proximity between the relationship and the kinds of things
that the copyright uh statute is meant to protect. And the kinds
of things that the copyright statute is meant to protect are
like economic relationships in general or something and markets.
>> Sure. If Ethan stopped live streaming and being a public
figure, do you think the snark people would keep going after
him the way they were? I >> I have no idea why that you
think that that's relevant to anything. >> Okay, that
then you should easily be able to give me a yes or no then. >> I
don't know whether or not >> if you don't think it's related,
you should easily give me a yes or no because you're obviously
not getting baited in anything. >> I just gave you an answer.
The answer is I don't know. >> You don't know? Okay. I
think it's a pretty easy guess to say that if he stopped being
a public figure and stopped live streaming and making money the
way he is.
>> Wait, if he stopped interacting online completely, how
would they interact with him?
Like, wouldn't that be basically
I think they would I think they would follow him like forever,
but it's just about whether or not um career and all weird. Okay.
I think it's I I just don't know how they'd interact with him
if he like was off the internet. If you had no public interactions,
>> those people would go the away and stop bothering him.
>> Wait, no. But all you have to do is change the hypothetical
of the relationship problem to have some sort of causal nexus
to the copyright issue and then I'm going to be able to make
you think that a person.
>> Yes. Yes. No. Hang on. I I will be able to make a hypothetical
that construct it in such a way as the the relationship issues
are bound up in the copyright. Yes. Do you doubt my ability to
do that? >> I think you could, but it would be so remote
as to not be relevant. >> I don't understand how. You're
saying the thing that's relevant, right? And I'm saying I'll
create a hypothetical in which we'll do it. And you're like,
well, I who cares if you do it? It'll because I just won't agree
anyway. But then why give me the >> because I'm talking
about a situation of real life facts in which I can say this
is a pretty easy conclusion to make. And you're saying, well,
I can fight the hypo hypothetical. That's >> yeah, you're
fighting the hype is not relevant. Just like you wouldn't answer
my you were like, oh, I don't know how your question is relevant.
So I'm say I don't know. Despite the answer being very clearly
no. >> I mean, so basically they would. So, so have you
ever had those like Jack Bower situations, moral issues, and
like you're like, "Would you think it's good to to torture this
person to save the world?" And you're saying like, "Well, I won't
answer that because it's so unrealistic." Are you one of those
people who like doesn't answer hypotheticals that aren't realistic?
>> I'm a person that can say, "I won't answer. I mean,
I can I didn't I didn't say I wouldn't answer your hypothetical.
I said it was irrelevant." If you want to spin the hypothetical,
I can give you >> Wait, that's what Pisco just did. Wait,
what? What are you complaining about >> I'm telling you
whether or not I think it's it weighs
if Episcoco didn't even say it was irrelevant. He was like, "I
don't understand how it's relevant." Pisco literally asked >> because
it is relevant, right? Because if you say that yes, you would
be against this lawsuit. >> I'm not Pisco. I don't deal
in
If you said that this lawsuit in which the issues of the relationship
are bound up in the issues of copyright or the stream or whatever
in the same way that the issues of harassment are bound up in
the stream, if you say that notwithstanding the fact that they
are bound up that nonetheless you would be against that lawsuit,
then it's clear that the bounding up isn't the isn't what's causing
you to have the difference of opinion >> because
if you keep the same if you keep the same thing, it doesn't change
anything. So there's something else going on.
>> That's the value of the hypothetical.
If the person well here here I can short circuit it and let me
see if this this helps. If the person who is suing under IP statute
because of a cheating situation would then and then no longer
sue them after that point if that person could like
I don't know went back in time and didn't cheat on them then
I guess so. But what we're talking about is like the ending of
the behavior of those people. You can't. The problem is is that
the cheating thing happened in the past. >> Well, no, hang
on. It's not like that because it's gonna stop. That doesn't
end there, right? >> No, I'll I'll [laughter] give you
the hypothetical. All right. So, this person is ongoingly cheating
and you want to stop cheating. So, that's because you >> Yes.
I was I have another one, too. If you don't want to buy that
one, but no, no, but let's use that one. >> That's fine.
We can talk about that one. >> They would they would stop
being unfaithful after the lawsuit.
>> Okay. So, if that person would justified
Wait, wait, wait. So, justified. Can you answer us? >> No,
I don't think that would be justif. >> So, why? Why? because
they're because they're the causalness of the Okay, >> there's
no way that Pisco is still arguing with CFKA that far into the
future, right? An hour and a half from now, there's no way. I
see people are like in his chat acting like he might be arguing
with CFKA still. I just want to see is that the lawsuit is directly
related to the relationship issue. So, why isn't it good to address
that harm done by that person who did infringe for the purpose
of getting them to stop doing that?
>> Uh, I don't think that the I think that the interpersonal
relationship of those people and the the judicial system in the
way are not supposed to be acting that way. I don't think that's
the >> Wait, that's exactly my point. That's my This is
why I'm doing what your point >> I know, but but your your
point I'm saying we disagree on that point. >> No, no,
but the proxy >> we disagree on the nature of the harm
that he was facing. >> But the but the nature of the harm
does not relate to infringement of copyright.
Um again,
uh even less I agree with this. I agree that Caseyron actually
almost certainly
almost certainly Is this live? It is live, but we're watching
like an hour and a half in the past. So Casey Tron almost certainly
could have fought that settlement, but then what if Ethan Klein
just goes and says, "Okay, I'll up then,
right?" Yeah. >> Um it of the copyright. Sure. But that's
not my issue. >> So the cheating thing >> I think
the judicial system was constructed in such a way to use it so
that you can use the IP thing to go after people for the things
that they're doing over in this other way regarding his his actions
in the market and stuff like that. >> Same wait. Same thing
for the relationship example. She infringed.
No,
>> I don't think that there's any part of the What part
of our our judicial system is about helping people enforce interpersonal
relationship issues >> all family law all the family law
and divorce law and if you are in married go if you are married
you cannot sue your wife over issues in your relationship that
is basic if someone's ongoingly cheating on you that's not the
court's
but you could sue your wife for a copyright issue right under
the pretense that like or basically under the pretense that She
violated your copyright in some way and you could make it disjoint
from your relationship. But it could be over the fact that she
said you're a fat. Could be over the fact that she said you had
a small dick, right? You could sue her for whatever. This stupid
[__] this stupid [__] said I'm not a
good husband.
She could sue you for anything. Or so you could sue her for any
of those reasons and that would be improper. And if you had reason
to suspect that those were the reasons,
then you could say it was improper for you to file a copyright
laws. >> Wait, wait. Do you think that there could be a
case in which uh fidelity bears on a legal analysis in in the
court of law enforceing
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. So that's the distinction. That's
the distinction. >> That's the distinction in the hypothetical
you presented me. >> Wait, no, no. So the distinction isn't
because courts don't ever get involved in personal matters cuz
that's false,
>> Okay. When >> So it could be relevant to a domestic
abuse analysis. It could be relevant to a sham marriage analysis
or repressive immigration. It could be re Yes. All this stuff
could be relevant. All of the the courts getting all say, "Hey,
don't worry. We're gonna help you to make sure your spouse stops
cheating." >> No, there's Wait, wait, no, that's not what
you asked. You asked whether or not a court will involve itself
in the personal uh the the affairs of people in >> in stop
the person cheating. That's what we're discussing right now.
>> No, they'll never give an order like that.
But that's not the question, >> which is why it's for someone
to USE AN IP LAWSUIT to get a judge to get them to stop cheating.
>> Okay. So, so long as it's improper. >> Wait, wait,
wait. You You're making this up. You realize that, right? >> What
do you mean? So you you realize that all these distinctions are
falling away and so now you're left on and I'm just going to
make another example that gets to this and we'll we'll we'll
isolate it because that's not really what's going on here >> and
you're just inventing new ones. You're like okay well the fact
that it's an ongoing thing and even though courts yes will address
past you won't address no but it's it's all ad hoc. It's all
ad hoc. It has nothing to do so I'll give you another example.
Okay so you're you're going to sue you do the infringement. All
right. And it's not going to order them to stop, it's not going
to cause them to stop doing uh infidelity. That's in the past.
But it will make them feel whole and it will cause them from
feeling anguished at the past infidelity. Now what? Proper or
>> Say that last part again. I'm very >> okay. The
lawsuit is being the infringement lawsuit is being brought for
the personal purpose and it's not going to result in any kind
of like change in the in the fidelity. That's all in the past.
But it will cause the person to who does the lawsuit to feel
whole again and at peace with respect to what happened. Okay.
>> In that context, justified or not, I >> I don't
I I don't think that that is a justified situation. No, I don't.
>> But but that's a situation in which that's a situation
which the copyright um the resolution of the suit is intricately
linked with the harm. It so the causally is related to the harm
um and the resolution of the case is related to harm and you
also have the court noting in into current status of um domestic
relations. I've isolated the
>> Okay. So you're saying like they had a past harm because
of the interpersonal >> Yes. It's an ongoing thing going
on. No, it's psychological. Sorry. Sorry. Okay. There's ongoing
psychological harm, but I I
>> I don't see it. I don't see how it's justified. No.
>> No. I've just isolated everything you've said. Right.
So, this is a case in which um it is bound up in how like the
determination of a lawsuit will resolve the harm. Will definitely
resolve the harm. And it does. >> Your your intuition is
telling you, "No, I still wouldn't I wouldn't like this." >> I'm
trying I'm just trying to I'm I'm sorry I'm very tired. I'm trying
to I'm genuinely trying to engage this. I I think I like Okay,
real quick. They're enforcing the IP which I could see it
>> I could see it being ethical and like they don't care
about like yeah they don't care about correct the IP the money
that that really doesn't matter at all. We're just saying just
to make sure. Sorry.
>> Because if that were the case I would be like okay who
cares, right? If they cared about it, you and I would agree,
right? They care about the thing, >> right? Right. We're
saying we're saying like we're not Right. Because the IP itself
is like is not even a factor in the psychological harm, right?
Because then then obviously it is, right?
24 minutes. Uh, we need uh what do we need here? Three subs.
Yeah, three subs for another hour. I am not feeling great, but
I would do more time. I do want to go through the Alex Jones
stuff. So, if we're going to have more time, you guys could do
that. If not, don't feel bad about it. Maybe um after stream,
maybe hang out in Discord or something. We'll see.
Not feeling like I'm not feeling like up to just consistently
be
yapping. I'm probably not like going to sleep, but I just don't
feel like I'm I'm a yapper right now. >> Obviously, it
is not Oh, then it's obviously justified, right? Yeah. >> Yes.
Right. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I'm just making sure I'm
tying it in right. >> Unless there's some like crazy circumstance
which you would like if Yeah. Right. >> Sure. Sure. Sure.
>> I think I think in that in that
>> Marmad, thanks for the gifted sub. Appreciate it, man.
>> I'm I'm still coming down.
I think I'm still saying that it's it's it's not, but like this
is tenuous, man. >> No, I I agree. >> We're getting
But that's what I mean. >> There's an easy answer. No,
[laughter] no, there's an easy
>> Chatty nickel. Thank you for the gifted >> answer
that explains everything, right? The easy answer that explains
the determinations as to where I agree with your intuition on
this one. I agree with your intuition on the last example as
well, but explains everything. >> Well, there's more honey.
That's cool. >> To have no care about the in
>> private hub, thank you for the gifted sub. That's another
hour on the stream. goddamn
care not like where there's some improper purpose, but like where
there is like just seriously like no care about any cognizable
interest that is motivating the copyright statute from an ethical
perspective that explains everything because once we have that
then like obviously that's trivially like not justified and it
predicts the problem is Kafka it predicts your disposition on
this case and I don't think you want to [laughter] I don't think
you >> I don't think it does because again I think that
the the motivations that I gave you are not so unrelated to the
IP that I think that it's an all but you already granted they
in virtue of it be so yes. So in virtue of it being causally
related to the disposition of a lawsuit doesn't make it bound
up in the IP issues. We just proved that with the last hypothetical.
And so all the snark stuff isn't related to underlying infringement.
It's other stuff, right? It's uh you know harassment with the
with the CPS skull. It's harassment with the with the skulls.
It's the kind of snark communities. It's not bound up in the
infringement issues. And having the causality turn on the disposition
of a suit doesn't make it bound up because we proved that with
the last hypothetical. >> No. I said I think no. because
I'm saying I think these things are of a kind
that they are this is like a categorical thing. I think there's
a category where IP issues exist such that they're related to
the things that I've been talking about harassment is IP related
fear of of financial harm by these people's actions. All right,
which I haven't said this whole time but by the way a lot of
it is them watching his over potentially violating his IP throughout
this whole thing. >> So, you know what I'm going to do?
>> I haven't brought it up but like you know that has been
happening this whole time, right? Kafka, I'm I'm just going to
make another hypothetical in which the financial harm is present
and will be amilarated, but it's just a different financial harm.
Okay? You're doing the copyright infringement because you want
to prevent this person from coming out and uh alleging that you
were unfaithful. Okay? Because you know that'll harm your business.
Go. >> Was I unfaithful?
>> Yes, you were. >> Okay. Well, then we've already
discussed the truth issues if it's true. >> No, but but
you don't care about that, right? You don't you don't care about
the unfaithfulness. who care about the revelation, the public
revelation because it'll do financial harm in justified or not.
You're assume you're >> he has to he has to say it's still
justified here under the basis of protecting your business. He
is justifying immoral behavior based on Ethan's financial concern.
Right? So he's this is Pisco is just giving him a different flavor
of justifying immoral behavior based on Ethan's financial concern.
He needs to he needs to delineate and explain why the specific
kind of like immoral behavior is okay. Right? And it can't just
be financial concern. There has to be something else. So now
there's a reasonable financial concern that if this person releases
a Google document on you alleging you're infid uh alleging infidelity
that you'll be hurting your business and you're going to sue
them from copyright and basically say well sign an NDA on this
issue or something, right? Sign an NDA on the infidelity or I'm
going to sue you dumbass,
right? Without directly, obviously it's illegal to directly imply
that, but that's essentially >> copyright to prevent the
woman from coming out with the expose.
You don't care about copyright at all. >> That's that's
purpose. You can't do the the explicit quid proquo. You can't
do that. Um because then that's obviously wrong and un unethical
in legal frameworks, too.
>> Or not. >> It's wrong. It's not cuz like I I don't
think you should use a copyright suit to prevent a true statement
from coming out. No. >> Wait. No. But no. Who cares about
that? It's financial harm. >> Okay. Yeah. I'm just going
to I'm going to change it to be alive. I keep taking I'm giving
you a holistic issue these things that are happening and you
were saying well here's one piece if I take it one piece that's
wrong and I'm saying well there's a collection of things together
of reasoning of why he's sense >> because it's not what
you're saying cuz when you bring up another consideration which
is well it's financial harm >> and I'm like well no that's
not it because here's an example where your answer is no when
you're like oh well it'll resolve the issue if you if the copyright
thing you know happens and the harassment will stop I give you
another example no well it's family issues you so we can just
keep adjusting it and the the latest thing you said doesn't help
you either. >> Why not? I'm telling you, there's all of
these things that add up to these things that to me make it similar
enough to >> So, the last thing I >> The last thing
you said is, okay, new rule. Anything related to a true statement
doesn't follow. >> That's not new. >> No. Okay. >> That's
not new. We said that the beginning of this. >> No. No.
It's new to this framework. But, okay, let's let's just adjust
it. All right. We're going to adjust it. You're suing for copyright
to prevent your wife from lying about an extra marital affair.
Go. >> I'm trying to prevent her from lying. >> And
doing it. Okay. I have I have probably I'm probably gonna find
that lawsuit ethical over the other one they mentioned. Well,
not over,
[laughter]
>> dude.
Oh, he's being such a weasel. Weasel weasel weasel. [laughter]
It's not It's not relative. I'm not asking a relative question.
>> I'm saying it's relative.
>> Wait, was there a good pause there?
Hold on. What's the best frame?
[laughter] Hold on. TAIWAN NUMBER ONE. TAIWAN NUMBER ONE. >> It's
not relative. I'm not asking the relative questions. I don't
know. That's what came to my mind. Okay. I don't care about that.
>> Probably say I this would probably say that that's ethical
to bring. >> So to sue someone even though you don't care
about the at all
>> to resolve an issue about her line >> financial
that would result in financial harm to me. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I think I think the prevention of of those kind of Yeah.
I think so probably ethical. So, so litigating lies about your
relationship through copyright usage >> that would result
in financial harm.
>> And why?
>> I think that our jud >> I think Pisco has to make
it
see here's the problem. Pisco is probably giving like obviously
then you have to find what what Denim said about Ethan that's
a lie, right? It's like not that clear. It would have to be like
at best you can give it a nebulous situation. It's not because
denims you denims isn't explicitly lying. So when you do collapse
back to the real example
>> system exists in such a way that we're trying to prevent
unjust financial harms to people. It's like a basic that's like
a that is a fundamental aspect of the American uh legal system.
>> Why wouldn't that be true of the uh of the true statement
that you could say that yeah it's true but it's no one's business.
It's true but it's no one's business and she's gonna she's trying
to take me down. That's unfair. So says the
>> won't won't I'm sorry that that feels that way to you
but we do not >> whether whether it's >> has an interest.
>> So basically CFKA is creating a framework where you
can never criticize somebody because you never know that thing
because CFKA is always going to say it's not on them to publicize
that. So they will always have plausible deniability. So while
he does say it comes down to whether it's true or not, whether
the thing they were saying was a lie or not, um in the case of
the relationship, you'll only like you might never know. It might
never be publicized. like you might never actually litigate that
in the public eye. And so he's basically saying if it's concerning,
you can't talk about it. Like it's it's actually it's ethical
to bring the lawsuit, you can't talk about it >> in this
context. Let's say for whatever reason the lie is is lawful to
say. It's lawful to say. She has a different view on what constitutes
infidelity.
>> Okay? I don't I I'm telling you for me, I do not view
lies as having some kind of um I I don't I don't view lies as
having um the same protections as truth. I I don't believe that
we should >> final final hypothetical. Same facts as >> We
can do more. I don't mind by the way. I'm not upset with you.
>> Same facts as before. Um with respect to the not caring
about stuff. Someone says that you
uh they're lying and they're saying uh in your mind they're lying.
Okay. They're saying that you support fascism and you don't support
fascism. >> And this is a lie. >> It's a lie. Well,
it's based on this >> Yeah. In this situation, he's calling
you a fascist and that's a lie. I've never said I support a fascist.
I'm not a fascist.
>> Copyright. Same thing.
And I'm suing him. It's just one second. I'm sorry. And there's
no financial interest here. >> There is. If if people believe
you're a fascist, I'm assuming you get less work. >> Well,
then I'll make a ton of money because I get to go work for TP
USA, right? So, no. Um, but no. Yes. If there's a financial issue
there, then yeah, like I would I would find that lawsuit to be
ethical in my mind. >> Okay.
So, >> I I like I I like if we're going to extract it out
this far, I could see. Yes. I would I would probably say that
>> Let's go one level deeper. It's kind of an interpretive
question. So they say you support genocide because you support
Israel, therefore you support genocide. And that's doing real
tangible harm to your business. All these allegations. Now they
don't say any untrue statements, but their interpretation is
a little whack.
So like like
I make some public statements. Maybe I say like what's happening
to God is horrible. 30,000 people have died. And they're like
he's saying the wrong numbers. >> No, but you support Israel.
You support Israel's war. >> Okay. Okay. That's fine. Okay.
We go further. I you know Israel's a right to defend itself.
Um Hamas God with a bunch of bad guys. And they're like, "That
means he supports genocide."
>> All right. And that's going to harm me
>> That's their interpret on my IP. >> According
to their Okay. And they they um infring on my IP. Now, and I'm
very sorry that I had to ask this question. I promise it's not
a weasel. I just want us to make sure we're understanding the
full extent of the hypothetical. Okay?
That is not the extent of everything. I >> I'll be honest.
I'm sort of ripping Pisco's content right now because I'm here,
but other content that might have happened or could be happening.
Okay? And I'm I'm just trying to figure out what I'm doing here.
I need some caffeine. I need some caffeine. I'm going to use
the bathroom and then I'm going to come back. But I'm going to
let you guys watch this. I'm sorry, Pisco. I'm stealing. I've
been transforming the whole time. I started like 20 minutes behind
your stream. I'm now an hour and 36 minutes behind your stream.
Okay. So, I've been transforming the whole time. Give me like
two minutes to just use you as white noise. Okay. Don't sue me
for this. It's like a chair react, but don't sue me for it. Okay.
If you register this stream with the Library of Congress, I'll
be devastated.
I'll be I'll be devastated.
This is not malicious infringement. It's like I just have to
use the bathroom and you could really help me out by letting
me play like just totally steal your content for two minutes.
Okay. Not malicious though. Thank you. >> I'm doing some
kind of please retract the statement reaching out beforehand
before I do the IP infringement lawsuit or anything like that.
Am I am I doing any of that or am I not doing that? I just want
to know. >> Let's start with not doing that. >> If
you don't do that, asking for a retraction of that statement
because actually this is something that we should have done very
early on. I think you do before you do these lawsuits. you the
IP lawsuits on these bases, you would need to reach out beforehand,
demand retractions of the statement, tell them the behavior they're
doing that they need to stop and if they don't, you're going
to proceed with the other thing. I would say that how would that
look? Apologize for CPS or apologize for what you said about
me and I won't bring a lawsuit because that that's just telling
us what we know and our intuitions are that's wrong. >> That's
wrong. If you want to sue him for copyright, sue for copyright.
Don't sue him for this other stuff that doesn't relate. No, I
don't think Well, I'm saying you couldn't I think that without
those I think that without those beforehand the ethical that
that you you're approaching it being it could be wrong. Um I
think it's possible it could still be right. I'm saying like
I would I would be less sure that you >> Wait, no, but
I'm asking you can say you don't know. So this is a situation,
right? It's the ambiguous kind of statements. You support Israel,
you support their occupation of Gaza, but you condemn the genocide,
right? Or something. Or you want to see and then they're like,
"Well, that's still genocide. You could be against it, but it's
your still support genocide and it's hurting you financially
and you're asking them to stop and it's kind of a ridiculous
interpretation almost. I'm not saying that it is. I'm just saying
in the context you feel it's a ridiculous interpretation and
it's hurting you financially. In that context, do you know that
it's justified or not?
>> In that context, I would say um I would say it's I would
still say yeah, I would say it's justified. I think it's the
subjective aspect of that is that yes, it would be justified
in that sense.
>> To resolve the issue about whether you support genocide
through a copyright
I think that in that scenario, the issue is whenever I'm thinking
about the justification of it, it actually has to come from the
perspective of the person bringing the lawsuit. And I would say
that person is justified because he thinks those people are lying
about his position of being a genocide, pro genocide. I would
say if he does not take any measures to try to humiliate it outside
of the court, I might I I would have a harder time saying that
it's an ethical situation. I think in that case, then it is an
abuse of the system and that he should not have done that. That
is unethical. If he made no attempts to resolve it outside of
the legal system, >> I'm changing a little bit. Assassan
[__] uh sues Lonerbox and says >> I was say
can we not >> dude um it's funny that that hypothetical
that quote unquote hypothetical is almost exactly what was really
happening right that Ethan was like well I support Israel but
I don't support the genocide that and then they're like no you
can't support Israel and like and not support the genocide. It's
essentially that like oh you support things Israel is doing but
you don't support the genocide. It's like no no I think all of
it is supporting the genocide. It's like, okay, whether or not
that's like a crazy argument to make, that's the argument. And
it's sort of subjective. It's not clear somebody's lying at all.
>> I just think it's very funny. >> [__]
uh sues Loner Box and says, >> I was going to say,
can we not use him? >> No, no, we're using him. Hassan
[__] um sues Loner Box for copyright. He doesn't
care about it. And the rationale is because Bonerbox is accusing
him of >> What? What the just happened
>> in the different >> Oh, so so brutal. Okay, we're
like an hour and a half behind. >> This is moral >> sense.
Moral. I would default it to
>> No, you could just say I don't know. Right. You need
some facts to say it's
>> No, I don't think you would. I would say I would I would
say that >> if there's a Wait, hang on a second. That was
my >> If there's a shooting between two people and one
of them is dead and lying on the ground, those are the only facts
you know. Are you going to say that's neutral? I would probably
say that my current assessment of this is it's >> No, you
wouldn't. >> You wouldn't say you have the belief that
it's neutral. [laughter] You would say I'm
>> I don't know. I don't know. You're making a declarative
statement. Yeah. Saying it's neutral is saying that you don't
know anything. You're saying nothing bad happened there, but
you objectively don't know.
>> Say that I have a I could say I could say like I could
I could give you a guess. I could say that like I like I need
to see what response is I don't know. Right. Well, my response
is like, let's stop and figure out what happened. >> Right.
So, you don't have a position. >> I don't know why. Like,
I don't know why I need to make a snap decision about morality
before I have all the facts. >> Right. Right. Right. So,
so you wouldn't say it's morally neutral based if you don't have
enough facts. You would need some facts to say it's morally neutral.
>> I don't know if I for me the way that I
>> You said you're fine with the apology aspect of the
settlement, just not the statement. Do you stand by that or is
the apology up too? No, the apology isn't [__] up.
Pisco doesn't think. Pisco thinks the exact same thing I do.
That things unrelated to the actual copyright infringement shouldn't
be in there. the apology over the copyright infringement. That's
saying you did something wrong. You wronged the other person.
That's fine to ask for that is under the purview of copyright.
What would you make what would make you think that Pisco or CFKA
weren't capable of far more than that? Wait, what? >> I
was I would say this right now I'm just going to keep this a
morally neutral thing. And so whenever I'm looking at like maybe
the ethics of it, right? So like the legal ethics, the fact that
those I agree with that makes me think like it's probably going
to end up moral, but I need to see more facts. Right? The guy
the fact that someone got shot in the ground, maybe it's probably
immoral, but right now I'm going to keep it a neutral ground.
I mean, you can call me like a psychopath with that, but I think
you're a psychopath. >> I'm being genuine. [laughter] I'm
being genuine when I say >> I think the proper response
is you withhold judgment if you don't have enough facts to determine
it. You need facts to say it's morally neutral, right? You you
could take the view that like there's a default state of actions
or something. Um, whatever. But, but I I kind of take the view
that if you don't know enough, you know, you don't have good
enough basis to to make a determination as to neutrality. I think
that you have to remain agnostic as to what the moral the moral
implications >> Well, but I don't know how I'm making some
kind of strong statement about the moral implications of saying
something's morally neutral. I'm not saying it's a strong implication.
I'm saying that that itself requires a determination. Okay. I'm
being told by people
that uh [laughter]
that Dan went on anything else
and he sh all over food shops. He was like there was never a
truce. I never agreed to a truce. This
and now food shops is having a meltdown about it. So,
I like I'm pretty excited about that. Okay. I think probably
that I'm very I'm like actually I'm actually getting sick. I'm
pretty sure again I'm very annoyed. But, uh I'm excited again.
So, I'm I'm I'm excited about this. I'm excited about
We're going to have to cover that I think tonight. We'll see.
We've got like a time stamp for the food drops react. We'll see
if we go find a time stamp for anything else. >> Well,
but my determination is that I don't have enough facts to make
a moral statement of whether it's moral or immoral. So, I'm going
to leave it as a neutral neutral thing and I'm going to continue
to get more facts so I can build out whether or not I determine
it isn't ne >> I'll be honest with you guys. I'm probably
going to take food chops aside
just because I do think it's very very funny and I keep saying
it. It's like how long can Dan, given what he's been saying about
Hassan, how long can Dan hang out in a VC with an actual before
somebody in Hassan's community picks that up and starts making
fun of them? You know what I'm saying? Like how long can you
guys hang out with this play arc raiders with them before somebody
is I think I'm just gonna take food shops inside. Okay, basically
the whole time
let's go food shops.
Let's go [laughter] neutral. It might end up actually being neutral
all the way down. That's possible. But it might also so I would
rather just start at the middle and then say okay I'm not going
to be biased like I'm not like biased towards it being neutral
or something. I'm going to say okay like I'm sitting here I'm
trying to figure out which side it falls onto. I'm gonna stay
in the middle until I know where to go on this. Me being entirely
agnostic, I guess I could just say I have no clue what it is
and just build my way towards one of those three. But like at
the end of the day, like if I get all of the facts of a situation,
I'm going to be at like one of those three. I would presume someone
who's like fundamentally ignorant about something like they just
show up to a scene of some stuff that happened. I think the right
view is I don't know whether this is moral. I need to get the
facts first and then oh, it turns out it's morally neutral. >> Yes.
But if someone said, "Okay, I've teleported you out of that scene.
you will never get the facts for that. Do you think that it was
moral or immoral? They say, "I think it's morally neutral." I
don't know. The answer is I don't I don't know. I >> mean,
I guess like I guess if you want to put it that way, that's fine.
I don't know why I don't know is such a a better answer than
morally neutral. Like what what are you ging
He can't like this is actually the case where I'm like, wait,
this CFKA guy, there's no way he went to law school almost. Like
that's that's really rough, right? Wait, if you don't know, isn't
that the same as saying it's morally neutral?
No, those are like the opposite. Those are like the opposite.
those are like the uh morally neutral is a determination you
come to based on facts. You have no facts. You can't make a determination
that some event was morally neutral, some happening was morally
neutral. You can't do that. It's the opposite. That's a determination.
Not knowing is a lack of a
It is the opposite. It's the absence of a determination. >> Like
the powers of neutrality or capability determination requires
some justification, right? >> Say something's neutral.
You have to know it's not saying that I have to make >> This
guy people will actually fundament like this guy is literally
hitting himself in the head with a hammer. Okay. He's like making
himself a second not so aerodyite just to be able to not like
say that this is bad. just to be able sorry not to not say that
he doesn't know like he's he's literally lowering his own IQ
so he can argue these things
what is h why would you do this what is >> immoral or immoral
>> to say something's neutral you need to know it's not
good and you need to know it's not bad right >> you can't
make a determination as to neutrality if you're unable to make
a determination as to whether it's good or bad because you need
you need to know
>> right but if but if neither of those >> if you
if you got all the facts and there was nothing good or bad if
you got all the facts And you got nothing good and nothing bad.
What would you call >> Um, it depends.
>> If Yeah. >> Wait, if you have all the facts, no,
no, no. If you have all the facts to make your determination,
you say it's morally neutral, then that is morally neutral. But
that's the whole point is Pisco is saying, I don't know. I don't
have enough information to come to a
>> If there's an action for which there is um, you know,
not enough uh to make a determination as to goodness or badness,
then I would be agnostic. But if you can say, "Okay, that I can
I know that's not good, but I also know it's not bad." You would
need to be able to make both.
>> Yeah. But if you're saying that you'd be agnostic on
something, how is that different from saying something's morally
neutral? >> Agnostic is not taking a view. Neutral is a
view. It's saying it's neither good nor bad. >> Okay. I
mean, maybe maybe we're just using these words differently here.
I mean, like I I don't know. It sounds to me like when I'm saying
something's morally neutral, it's saying it's neither good nor
bad. And
>> like right now, based off of the facts I've received,
it's neither good nor bad that he's brought this >> lawuit.
But but to know it's neither good nor bad, you need to know it's
not good. And you know it's not bad, right? >> Yes. But
I'm only speaking to you with the facts that I currently possess.
>> Yeah. And the facts I'm making an assessment based off
of the facts I currently possess. It is morally >> So So
you have facts that lead you to believe it's not good.
>> I don't have any facts to believe that it's not good.
Nor do I have any facts that it is like immoral. >> Okay.
If you don't have enough facts to believe it's not good, then
you don't have enough facts to believe it's >> Why not?
>> Because in order for something to be neutral, it needs
to be both not bad and not good.
>> Oh no. I I think that something can be neither. And
>> like
Pisco gave the perfect thing, right? The the hypothetical they're
talking about is you come to like some place you see that there's
like a person dead on the ground and another one holding a gun
and you go this is morally
You have no idea if it's morally neutral. You can't say it's
morally neutral. You could say you don't know. You could say
you shouldn't take a position until you know more. But that's
not morally neutral. That's morally neutral is saying I know
that nobody is a bad actor here.
But you can't make that determination with no other facts
obviously. Has anyone ever changed their view on this lawsuit
yet? Or is it just talking to walls every time? Um no. Lots of
people have changed their minds like in conversations
like about little things. There is a lot of talking to walls.
This guy is literally like
the entirety of his engagement online depends on him being in
this conversation. And so obviously he's going to remain in this
conversation.
Like he writes stuff for Destiny's like newspaper thing. He engages
in DGG. He goes on Destiny's stream. Everything he does on the
internet relies on him being stupid in this conversation.
Pisco did. Pisco stole your bit. Wait, what do you mean? What
do you mean Pisco? Wait, what? I Dude, I lost what I was even
saying that you guys are responding to, but you both said the
same thing, so it must make sense. Oh, debating DG Defenders.
Oh, I see. I see. Yeah. No, people have changed their mind with
me arguing as well. I think like pump Didn't Pumpern Nickel change
his mind? Well, Pumpernner Nickel had some crazy points. There
people in my community have their mind changed, but I'm also
not like you can massage people's egos to get them to change
their mind, right? I've I've just stopped doing it cuz it's actually
depressing when you like you do this very slow like good faith
walkthrough with people and then they just reset. That that will
break you after enough times. It'll break pistol after enough
times. It's very very depressing.
>> And then just be morally that's what I just said before
it doesn't >> but in order something be more than neutral
needs to be neither good nor
>> Yes. But it can be neither good or bad by absence of
having anything good or bad about it. >> Right. You need
to know both. >> Okay. Right now I have an absence of it
being good or bad. I don't have the facts showing me that this
>> How do you know it's Wait, hang on. You don't have the
facts to establish it's not good, right? >> Yes. Okay.
So, if you don't have the facts to establish it's not good, how
can you determine that it's neutral?
because I don't have any facts that determine that it's good.
So therefore, I default to neutral. >> Oh, you need you
need to be able to make a determination as to not goodness, don't
you? >> Yes. And what I'm saying is if there was a if I
needed to reach a threshold of 100 not goodness for it to be
immoral, I am currently not at that threshold.
And I'm the same for the threshold of something being good. And
if I have met neither threshold, then it is neutral to
>> All right. What's I blow my nose? >> No, you're
fine. there and you can't are
morally neutral actions that you determine to be morally neutral
even though you can't determine whether they're not good
and you can't determine whether they're not bad.
Believe that is what I've said.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm trying to make sure I'm being precise here that I if I don't
have the if I don't have >> Oh, I forgot. Also, Steam sale's
on. I'm probably going to go home for Christmas. I'm looking
for something for the Steam Deck. I don't know what to play.
I I'm thinking like an a little RPG or something, but I don't
know. I also don't know if I want to take time off stream. So,
like I might take my laptop back with me and just stream anyway.
But I I probably want to buy a game and just like play something
like a little bit. I don't know. I'm trying to think of it. I'm
thinking like a game that's three, four years old. I ah [sighs and gasps]
you ever played? Yeah, I've played Tactics Advance. I've never
played like the original tactics, but I don't think there's enough
there that I really need to go and check it out. So, Cyberpunk,
it's funny that BB Poison said Cyber Punk. Cyberpunk is what
I'm thinking. But the only thing is I don't know if I can play
Cyber Punk on my deck.
Um cuz Cyber Punk is cheap and I was like, why isn't it cheaper,
but I've heard it's like really good and I've never played it.
Is it at all like like Oblivion or something? Is it at all like
that or is it more like are there other games you compare it
to? Oh, the E33 game. What the what what is it called?
It's like some French word 33, right?
Whatever that is. I think I've I've seen that game. I know people
like it.
Expedition. Oh, no. Cl Oh, Claire Obscura is what I was thinking
of.
Is that the Wait, is that the same?
Are those the same game
or are those different games?
I'm sorry. I literally don't play I don't look at games. It's
the same game. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Clare Obscure Expedition 33. All right. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
That might be worth playing. Cyberpunk.
Okay. Maybe Cyber Punk's worth playing, too. Okay.
40k Rogue Trader I heard is good, too. I've heard okay things
about that.
Be failing my homies if I didn't recommend Digimon Time Stranger.
I saw that on sale and I was like, I wonder if that could be
good. I feel like as a 30-year-old man playing a Digimon game,
I there's something about it where I'm just like, I don't think
I can do that. I can play Cyberpunk, but I don't know if I can
justify playing Digimon.
I I hate to say it. Somehow in my head, playing that Digimon
game I feel like is
adjacent. Unironically,
I I feel like that. I feel like there's just something weird
about playing games made for like little kids as an adult. I'm
sorry. I don't And I know that's unreasonable. I don't expect
other people to hold to that standard. But somehow in my mind,
there's like something going on there where it's like I've reached
an age where I'm like, I actually don't think I should do that.
I don't think I should cross that line.
Makes you feel better. The MC isn't a teenager. Okay. Is that
cuz they're 10 or Why do you think Queen liked it liked it so
much, dude?
Okay. Yeah, I know there's a most popular, but I I'm looking
for like a combination. I think I think it's cyberpunk. I think
it's cyberpunk. I think I think >> the facts to make a
determination one way or the other, then I default to >> Don't
you need to have a justification for not good and justification
for not >> No, I No, I don't need a justification for not
good or not bad. I only need I need a justification for good
or a justification for bad. >> How do I prove something
is neutral?
>> What do you mean proving something is >> Yeah,
how do I prove >> I Okay, if I was going to prove
>> Okay, basically what CFKA is saying, I have a scale.
I have like 10. I'm gonna get you to weigh 10 things. Okay. I
haven't put anything on the scale yet.
The scale is rating neutral. Are the the items I'm going to hand
you, are they going to be equal in weight? I've not handed you
a single item yet to put on the scale on either side. Are they
going to be equal in weight? And he's like, well, yeah, that's
neutral. It's like, no, no, I'm asking the question is this event,
this this thing once you once you actually know all the facts,
is it going to be even? And he's like, "Yes, based on the fact
that it's even now when I know nothing." Like, you are making
a totally worthless statement. You understand that, right? You're
you're saying it's morally neutral, which is a deter determination,
but you're making that determination based on no information.
Your determination is worthless. And you're like, "Yeah, but
it's neutral." >> Cool. I think it was neutral. I there
is there is nothing here that would allow me to call this moral
or then there's also nothing here that allows me to call this
immoral. >> I do not possess that. So, I cannot therefore
call it one of those two things. So therefore, I'm going to default
to neutral.
>> So if you don't have enough information to determine
whether something is good, and if you have not enough information
to determine something is bad, it's therefore neutral.
>> Yes, that's what I would say. That's what I would call
it in in terms of >> I don't agree, but
that's fair. This is this is why I don't like talking about morality
because we get into very weird personal language. Am >> I
crazy, guys? You guys tell me if I'm >> Maybe I'm crazy.
It's you don't like talking about morality right now because
you are trying to hide that you're defending immoral behavior.
That's why you don't like talking about morality.
If you were just acting in a moral way, you wouldn't have any
concern about talking about morality. Like you're just trying
to defend immoral behavior. That's obviously why you're [__]
around right now. It's like saying, "I don't know what the pH
of some liquid is, so it's neutral." You need to know the pH
is seven to say it's neutral.
>> it feels like in order for you to establish something
as neutral, you need to deny both its goodness and its >> I
mean it's it's fair like I I respect your position. I'm not I
don't I don't think that you are wrong. >> Someone says
hypnotize hypnotist says everything is neutral unless you know
additional facts. Drinking soda is neutral. Drinking your own
soda you bought is moral. Stealing someone else's soda is not
moral. Pretty easy. In order to know drinking soda is neutral,
don't you first need to know it's not good and it's not bad?
How do how do you just how else would you determine its neutrality?
I don't I I just think that I think that I'm using the word neutrality
here. I think that for you >> you're using the word in
a way you're literally reinventing the English language,
right? He's re he's reinventing the English language how it's
used with regards to morality to defend an indispensable position.
like he just keeps he keeps misunderd,
it's bad, it's neutral. And I have three categories of it's good,
it's bad, or it's neutral.
>> Oh my god.
I never want to talk about this lawsuit again, dude. It >> that's
that's fine with me. I come here to talk about it.
That's fine with me. That's fine with me. Yeah, it is fine with
you. This like the thing is I get it. I get what Pisco I get
where Pisco is going. It's like people come in and like try to
be performatively to gaslight you and then you're like, I never
want to talk about this again. And then they're like, "Yeah,
that's what I wanted."
I know that's what you wanted, you
>> The haters [laughter] win. The haters. But this we need
to be we really need to be done. We we really >> that's
fine. >> Be done. Um >> no worries. I don't mind.
>> I can't help but summarize though. So you Pisco needs
to actually
unfortunately again this this mysterious call that definitely
doesn't exist on the internet anywhere where Pisco and Zip Zip
argued this and then Quimman had a couple tips for for Pisco.
Quan helped him out and I I can't help but think that Pisco will
probably hear these words echoing.
Uh, Pisco, you have to start showing strength to these people.
You have to actually start telling them what they are, what they're
doing, what they look like to everybody. Start explaining to
them when they do these things how moronic they look, how they
look totally stupid. Tear their arms off and beat them to death
with them. Okay? Like the wookie you are, pull their arms out
of their sockets and start windmilling, okay?
It's just it has to happen cuz otherwise they will never feel
shame. They will never improve. They're going to be stuck in
this loop where they endlessly justify
all the time forever. Um, you can't ask about it in here. >> you
believe it's neutral because you don't have enough evidence to
show it's goodness or badness, right?
>> You don't support it. You wouldn't have done it and
you don't think he should have done it. >> That is that
is a that is Yes. That is a reduction of the things that I've
told you. Yes. >> Hey, want to talk about some fun for
like a minute? >> I do, actually. >> All right. Um,
talk to me. Oh sh Ryan Mali. Holy >> Oh, get him in here.
Get him in here. Get me. I'm gone. Get him. Go get him. Please
go. >> I
Kofka. Hypnotized me.
>> You piece of Oh my god. Oh, I'm such an >> No,
Ryan. Ryan got He He sent me in here to distract you cuz he's
so afraid of >> I I totally him over. >> Oh no. I'm
so sorry. What? Were you supposed to meet him or something? >> We
were supposed to do it at 9:00. >> Oh, I didn't know that.
I'm sorry. I know that. >> I need to I I just need to stop
this this I I get obsessing. >> Jesus Christ. Genu, I'm
genuinely sorry. I know that like >> Oh, it's not your
fault. It's my fault. >> Yeah, even still. Look, go see
if you can you go see if you can. >> Why didn't he show
up in chat? Why didn't you show up in chat? >> It is weird.
>> I got See if you can go and get him back on the horn.
Go see if that's a way better combo than what we just had. That's
a way that's going to be a way better video that you can make.
>> Oh, what you trying to tell me? You were trying to tell
me. I didn't see it. I didn't see it. >> And I apologize.
>> I was looking at chat. I would have seen it. Oh no.
He's going to hate me. He's going to hate me. He's going to hate
me. >> Dude, this is actually sick. There are people in
Pisco's community
that are telling CFKA a good job.
And I don't think it's because they thought he did a good job.
I think I think they're telling I think people are trying to
guess I think
I there are some sick individuals out there. Okay. Some very
sick sick individuals out there who will gas up these total.
It's not good, man. It's not good. It's not good. Okay. All right,
I think we're basically done.
I think I lost Pisco. What do you mean? I think I'm bummed, dude.
I think I lost Pisco. Wait, what do you mean, Kilo?
You talking about the CFKA conversation or something else? Did
you go talk to him? Cuz you were donating. You said he didn't
want to cover this anymore. Well, I know he doesn't want to cover
it anymore, but he doesn't want to cover it anymore because like
it it's like you're peeling off the mask of humanity.
Like there's this vague mask of humanity that certain of your
viewers wear. You're peeling it off and realizing that they're
like actual
like brain dead demons that are just coming in to like waste
your time forever and ever and ever and ever and ever and ever.
And it's like, well, I guess I can't talk about this anymore.
I guess I guess not.